LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS --
WELCOME TO OUR GOVERNMENT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HEARING JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING RULES LIKE USUAL --
WE HEAR BILLS IN SIGN IN ORDER
WE HAVE TWENTY ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH
IS AB.
SIX THIRTY TWO AND ITEM TWELVE
WHICH IS AB.
TEN EIGHTY FOUR WILL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED.
IN ORDER TO MOVE THROUGH OUR
AGENDA -- IN A QUICK MANNER
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ALLOWED TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. TO
WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION BEYOND
THESE LIMITS PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION FOR BREVITY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- WE HAVE -- WE'RE
GOING TO ACT AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AT THIS POINT SO WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND START.
IN OUR FIRST BILL THIS AFTERNOON
IS ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR AB FOR EIGHTY FIVE MISTER
MEDINA.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
TODAY I RESENT AB.
FOR EIGHTY FIVE AB FOR YOU FIVE
SIX TWO IS EXPAND ON CURRENT LAW
TO INFORM THE PUBLIC WITH MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION.
WHEN LOCAL DISTRICTS APPROVED
TAXPAYER FUNDED SUBSIDIES FOR
WAREHOUSE DISTRIBUTION CENTERS?
REACH RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT
WAREHOUSES ARE NOT BENEFITING
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY'RE BUILT IN.
THE ECONOMIC POLICY INSTITUTE
REPORT ENTITLED UNFULFILLED
PROMISES.
ECONOMIST STATE THAT AMAZON
FULFILLMENT CENTERS ARE
INEFFECTIVE AND PROVIDING NET
JOB GROWTH.
SOME OF THE JOBS ARE TEMPORARY
SEASONAL.
AND FUTURE PLAN FOR AUTOMATION
CAUSING EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO FLUCTUATE.
AND THROWING FAMILIES INTO
ECONOMIC INSTABILITY.
THIS BILL IS AIMED AT HOLDING
THOSE COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE TO
THE PROMISES MADE WHEN SUBSIDIES
WERE BEING ASKED.
FOR WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS SERRA FLOCKS FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
AND SHERRY OUR HOUSE JEAN FROM
THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS RESOURCE
CENTER [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THEIR FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND LABOR FEDERATION
HAS A LONG HISTORY OF ADVOCATING
FOR ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND JOB STANDARDS
ON PUBLIC SUBSIDIES BOTH AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL.
AND THIS BILL CONTINUES THAT
TRADITION AND ONE OF THE REASONS
WE DO THAT IS BECAUSE EVERY
DOLLAR THAT GOES OUT IN A LOCAL
SUBSIDY TO A BUSINESS.
IS A DOLLAR THAT CAN'T BE USED
FOR OTHER PRIORITIES LIKE PARKS
ROADS SCHOOLS AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SAY WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE A TAXPAYER SUBSIDY TO A
BUSINESS.
THAT MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
ARE GETTING A RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT AND TO BE CLEAR THE
DISCLOSURE REQUIRED IN THIS BILL.
ONLY APPLIES WHEN A WAREHOUSE
TAKES A SUBSIDY OF OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO DISCLOSE
ANY OF THE INFORMATION THEY
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE THE LOCAL
SUBSIDY -- THEY CAN GET
SUBSIDIES IN OTHER PLACES OR
JUST LOCATE AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT REALLY SAYS OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU A
SUBSIDY WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT
KIND OF JOBS YOU'RE CREATING
WHAT ARE THE QUALITY ARE THEY
GOING TO HAVE BENEFITS ARE THE
TEMPORARY ARE THEY PART TIME.
AND WE WANT TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION IN A PUBLIC MEETING
SO THE COMMUNITY WILL KNOW WHEN
YOU HAVE THESE MILLION SQUARE
FOOT WAREHOUSE IS MOVING IN WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE GETTING.
BECAUSE THE LAST THING WE WANT
IS FOR LOCAL TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
BE GOING TO A WAREHOUSE THAT
BEEN PAYS SO LITTLE THAT WORKERS
AND UP ON MEDI CAL OR OTHER
PUBLIC BENEFITS BECAUSE THAT IS
DOUBLE DIPPING AND IT DOESN'T.
IMPROVE THE ECONOMY IN THOSE
AREAS.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON FOR PARTS OF
THIS BILL THAT ARE DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT WAS IN THE BILL LAST
YEAR THAT THE COMMITTEE HEARD.
WHICH I THINK IMPROVE THE BILL
ONE IS THAT WE REQUIRING
REPORTING ON ANY PLANS FOR
AUTOMATION. TO KNOW WHAT JOBS
ARE GOING TO BE ELIMINATED WE
ARE ALSO SET OUT ASKING FOR
REPORTING TO GO BIZ THE STATE
AGENCY SO WILL BE EASY FOR US TO
SEE.
GET A PICTURE OF WHERE SUBSIDIES
ARE GOING ACROSS THE STATE WERE
ASKING IF THERE IS ANY JUST FOR
THIS THE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
DISCLOSE IF THERE'S ANY KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY OR CLAW BACK.
AND INCLUDED IN THE CONTRACT AND
LASTLY THERE IS A BAN ON NON
DISCLOSURE AGREEMENT SIGNED
BETWEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN THE
WAREHOUSE -- AND DISTRIBUTION
CENTERS DURING NEGOTIATIONS FOR
THE LIFE OF THE CONTRACT PARTLY
THAT COMES OUT OF THE FACT THAT
AMAZON.
WENT THROUGH AND DID A
COMPETITION GOT ALL THIS
INFORMATION FROM COMMUNITIES AND
THEN NO ONE OF THE COMMUNITY WAS
ALLOWED TO KNOW WAS IN THE DEAL
THEY MADE THEM SIGN
NONDISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS WHICH
WE THINK IT'S FUNDAMENTALLY.
ANTI DEMOCRATIC ANTI TRANSPARENT
FOR THAT REASON WE'RE PROUD TO
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WELCOME THANK YOU --
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE -- GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS SHERRY ARE COST YOU
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER RESOURCE CENTER.
WE'RE A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
BASED IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA FOCUSED ON
SUPPORTING WAREHOUSE WORKERS
ESPECIALLY LOW WAGE WORKERS
WAREHOUSE WORKERS IN THE SECTOR
AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THROUGH EDUCATION ADVOCACY IN
ACTION -- THEM HERE BECAUSE THIS
BILL IS SOMETHING THAT WILL.
ESPECIALLY BENEFIT OF FOLKS IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE REGION BUT
ALSO ACROSS INLAND HEALTH
SOUTHERN ISLAND CALIFORNIA --
LAST TWENTY YEARS WAREHOUSING
AND DISTRIBUTION IS BECOME A KEY
SECTOR OF THE INLAND CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY -- OVER FIVE HER MILLION
SQUARE FEET OF WAREHOUSING SPACE
THE POINT OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE -- HAVE COME
INTO THE INLAND REGION IN THE
LAST TWENTY YEARS THERE'S OVER --
TO FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ACROSS
THE STATE ARE EMPLOYED IN
WAREHOUSES.
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT LEADERS
HAVE CLAIMED THAT LOGISTICS THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY FOR JOB GROWTH
IN THESE AREAS.
AS A RESULT MUNICIPALITIES ARE
OFFERING MAJOR TAX INCENTIVES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
SUBSIDIES TO EMPLOYERS TO SITE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ACCORDING -- TO ONE SOURCE GOOD
JOBS FIRST OVER FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN SUBSIDIES
HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO FREIGHT
LOGISTICS COMPANIES IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
AT THE SAME TIME THE QUALITY OF
THE JOBS CREATED BY THESE
FACILITIES IS INCONSISTENT ON
CLEAR.
RESEARCH BY UCLA INTO THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN FOUND THAT OVER
HALF THE WAREHOUSE JOBS IN THESE
FACILITIES IN ONTARIO.
WERE EMPLOYING WORKERS WERE
INPUT CLING MAJORITY OF WORKERS
THROUGH STAFFING AGENCIES AT OR
CLOSE TO MINIMUM WAGE WITH NO
BENEFITS.
NO CONSISTENCY OR ABILITY TO
KNOW IF YOU'LL HAVE WORK THE
NEXT DAY A LITTLE ON THE NEXT
WEEK.
THESE CONDITIONS ARE
UNACCEPTABLE.
LAST YEAR THE BROOKINGS
INSTITUTION SUPPORTED BY
REGIONAL BUSINESS GROUPS OF UP
TO REPORT ON THE REGIONAL
ECONOMY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
I FOUND THAT WHILE WAREHOUSE JOB
WHAT WAREHOUSE GROWTH HAS --
DRIVEN EMPLOYMENT GROWTH AND IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS.
IN THAT PERIOD.
WAIT WAIT JUST AN EARNINGS OF
ACTUALLY DROPPED AND THE POVERTY
RATE HAS IT ACTUALLY INCREASED --
FIT FOCUSING OUR REGIONAL
ECONOMY ON THIS SECTOR HAS
ACTUALLY BEEN DETRIMENTAL SINCE
THE TWO THOUSAND BROOKINGS
RECOMMENDED TO THE ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
I COMING TO THAT UP DEVELOPING
AGENCIES OF THE REGION THAT THEY
STOP FOCUSING AS MUCH ON
WAREHOUSING AND DISTRIBUTION AND
LOOK AT OTHER INDUSTRIES LIKE
MANUFACTURING.
WE THINK THAT THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY OPPORTUNITY HERE FOR US
TO LOOK AT THE WAY HOUSING HAS
BEEN BUILT A NEW WAREHOUSE AND
IS COMING INTO THIS REGION.
AND ASK FOR TRANSPARENCY AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THESE TO BE GOOD
JOBS -- THIS BILL IS JUST A
SMALL STEP IN THAT DIRECTION TO
KNOW WHAT KIND OF JOBS ARE BEING
CREATED HOW MANY -- AND WHAT YOU
KNOW WHAT OPPORTUNITIES WILL BE
MADE TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES -- THE
CURRENT DISCLOSURE LAWS ARE
INADEQUATE AND THAT NUMBER OF
NUMBER QUALITY OF JOBS ARE NOT
THAT ARE BEING CREATED NOT CLEAR --
WITH SEVERAL INSTANCES IN
EXAMPLES OF THAT HAPPENING IN
OUR COMMUNITY -- QVC -- OP OPEN
THE WAREHOUSE IN ONTARIO IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THERE IS TO BOTH
STATE CALIFORNIA COMPETES BUT
ALSO LOCAL SUBSIDIES FROM THE
CITY OF ONTARIO -- THE CITY
OFFERED FIFTY TO THIS DAY THE
COMPANY 55% OF THE TAX REVENUE
TO BE RETURNED TO THE COMPANY --
THEY TOLD THE STATE THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE OVER NINE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES BY NOW BUT I DRIVE BY
THAT FACILITY ALMOST EVERY DAY
ON THE WAY TO WORK.
AND THERE'S NEVER MORE THAN
FIFTY OR SIXTY CARS IN THE
PARKING LOT -- TO ISSUE MERCHANT
HOME SHOPPING NETWORK LAST YEAR
HOME SHOPPING WHAT NETWORK
RECEIVED -- SIMILAR TAX
ABATEMENT FROM THE CITY OF
FONTANA RIGHT NEXT DOOR 50% OF
THE TAX -- BIZRATE RETURNED IN
FONTANA TO HOME SHOPPING NETWORK
NOW THAT SAME COMPANY THAT NOW
MERGED COMPANY IS OFFERING TO
FACILITIES -- WITH THESE TAX
ABATEMENTS BUT AT THE SAME TIME
IT'S NOT CLEAR HOW MANY JOBS
HAVE BEEN CREATED AND WHAT THE
BENEFITS ARE TO THE COMMUNITY.
AND FINALLY AMAZON ONE OF THE
RICHEST COMPANIES OF THE WORLD
IS PLAYING THIS GAME.
AFTER RECEIVING SIGNIFICANT
STATE TAX INCENTIVES IN TWENTY
TWELVE TO OPEN IN SEVERAL
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THEY RECEIVED --
ABATEMENTS FOR THE CITY OF
FRESNO FOR UP TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WINNERS IN THE CITY OF FRESNO
SUPPOSED TO THIS BILL AND WE ASK
WHY WHY ARE WE ALL WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS TRANSPARENCY ABOUT.
THE SIGNIFICANT DEVELOPMENTS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES.
RESCUE FOR INFORMATION ABOUT
PLAN FOR GROWTH GROWTH.
IN INCLUDING AUTOMATION US SOME
THAT'S COMING REALLY QUICKLY IN
THE SECTOR.
WE'RE ASKING WHY CITIES NEED TO
HOLD NON DISCLOSURE AGREEMENTS
WITH DEVELOPERS WAREHOUSE
OPERATORS ABOUT THESE KEEP
WORKING CONDITIONS FOR THE
SECTOR -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
ON BEHALF THE TEAMSTERS ARE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT
IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS JAZZY GROWTH
UFCW WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
SUPPORT THANKS HANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYWAY EVERYONE ELSE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS THE ENGINE
THAT EVE CAM A STRATEGY IN
ADVOCACY HERE REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF FRESNO.
AND WE ARE HERE RESPECTFULLY AND
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED --
POSITION -- WERE STRONGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE
ADDITIONAL DISCLOSURES THAT ARE
REQUIRED AND WE'RE CONCERNED
THAT THEY MAY BE DIFFICULT TO
PROVIDE -- AND IT COULD AFFECT
OUR ABILITY TO REMAIN
COMPETITIVE AMONG OTHER STATES
IN THE TRACK GOOD PAYING JOBS
JUST FOR YOUR BACKGROUND FRESNO
HAS SEEN UNPRECEDENTED X.
UNPRECEDENTED SUCCESS WITH THREE
AECOM ARE CENTERS -- COMING TO
OUR REGION THESE DEVELOPMENTS
HAVE HELP CHIP AWAY AT AWAY AT
THE GENERATIONAL POVERTY THAT
WE'VE EXPERIENCED -- WENDY AND
WE HAVE AT LEAST FOUR THOUSAND
ESTIMATED NEW JOBS BECAUSE OF
THESE DEVELOPMENTS.
I'M ADDITIONALLY THEY HAVE SENT
FRESNO IS UNEMPLOYMENT RATE TO A
HISTORIC LOW WHICH IS AROUND 6% --
WHICH IS GOOD FOR FRESNO HOWEVER
WE STILL HAVE 30% OF OUR
POPULATION -- STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE WITH INCOMES UNDER THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LINE AND AND
THAT STILL FAR BEHIND
CALIFORNIA'S FOUR POINT 2%
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE.
IN SHORT WE'RE STILL VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN CREATING NEW JOBS
FOR THE REGION WHICH EIGHT AND I
KNOW IS ALSO SHARED INTERESTS
THAT THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS
HAVE -- WE CERTAINLY DO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
AND HAVING GONE INTO THESE TYPES
OF AGREEMENTS WE HAVE A VESTED
INTEREST IN ENSURING THAT -- THE
PROJECT PROPONENTS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PROVISIONS
THAT WE AGREED -- TO VERY MUCH
ARE INCENTIVES THAT ARE GIVEN
ARE DIRECTLY TIED TO NET JOBS
THAT ARE ADDED FOR FRESNO SO WE
HAVE -- VARIOUS MECHANISMS TO
ALSO PROVIDE LOOK BACKS WITHIN
OUR AGREEMENTS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT MAY NOT BE THE CASE FOR ALL
MUNICIPALITIES BUT THAT'S VERY
MUCH SOMETHING THAT FRESNO HAS
BEEN PASSIONATE AND ENSURING
THAT THERE'S THAT LET MEASURE OF
CASH ACCOUNTABILITY -- HOWEVER
WHERE IT WE ARE CONCERNED THAT
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY FIVE MAY HAVE
SOME COME.
IN THERE THAT -- REQUIRE PREPARE
PROPRIETARY DATA -- ANYTHING
THAT JUST LEAVES IN A PLACE OF
UNCERTAINTY WE'RE NOT SURE IF
THAT INFORMATION WILL BE
FURNISHED TO US SINCE AND THAT
PUTS US IN AN UNTENABLE POSITION
OF WONDERING -- YOU KNOW WILL WE
SNOT WELL WE NO LONGER SEE THE
KIND OF SUCCESS THAT WE HAVE
SEEN WITH THESE ECONOMIC
INCENTIVE AGREEMENTS IN THE PAST
I'M IF THIS BILL IS PASSED WITH.
SOME OF THESE PROVISIONS -- AC
UNIT WE THINK THAT WITHOUT THE
WITHOUT SPECIFIC CHANGES WHICH
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE ON WERE CONCERNED THAT
THIS COULD HAMPER OUR ABILITY TO
DIVERSIFY OUR ECONOMY.
AND RAISE WAGES AND LOWER ARE
STUBBORN UNEMPLOYMENT RATE SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON AND OTHERS ON THIS IN
THE SPONSOR ON THIS AS WELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS KATE
FELL ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE ALSO
HAVE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION -- WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RELEASE OF A
LOT OF THE PROPRIETARY AND
FINANCIAL INFORMATION -- TO THE
PUBLIC AND THAT'S TO COMPETING
BUSINESSES -- WE WOULD REMOVE
OUR POSITION IF THE AUTHOR WOULD
DELETE -- THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL TO REQUIRE US TO RELEASE
THAT PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
SALARIES WAGES.
CONTRACTORS AT SO LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE OTHERS OFFICE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MANAGER MEMBERS MET THE HEART OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUSINESS
PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION -- OUR
MEMBERS DEVELOP THESE PROJECTS
MANY TIMES WE DON'T KNOW WHO'S
GOING TO BE IN SOME OF THESE
AREAS AND REQUIRE SOME OF THIS
INFORMATION BEFORE THAT HAPPENS
WITH FEELS UNTENABLE AND WE
OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE -- ENTERTAIN A
MOTION -- ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND SO WE'LL GET BACK TO YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO IT WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER MEDINA WHEN
YOU HAVE A FOR MY LITTLE ****.
FOR YES.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK.
NEXT WE WILL HAVE A
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB SIX EIGHTY NINE
WELCOME MISTER MCCARTY.
YOU CAN START.
YES THANK YOU -- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF OUR FIRST TOP WANT TO
SAY THAT -- WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANK YOU FOR WORKING.
WITH WITH ME AND MY LOCALS HERE
AT SMUD -- TO TO GET THIS BILL
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
THIS IS A AB SIX NINETY EIGHT A
DISTRICT BILL FOR THE SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL YIELDS UTILITY
DISTRICT ARE A LOCAL UTILITY
SERVING THE GREATER SACRAMENTO
AREA WHICH ALLOW THEM TO RECEIVE
A NON STOCK EQUITY IN A COMPANY.
SOMETHING THAT'S ALREADY ALLOWED
FOR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY
SHAREHOLDERS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA.
THIS OF COURSE IS A A PUBLIC
AGENCY WHO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE -- PROTECTIONS BUT
ALSO THE SAME OPPORTUNITIES AT
OUR INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
HAVE.
AS MOTHER RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER A
CYNICALLY ENGAGED IN THE
FOREFRONT OF DE CARBONIA D.
CARBON ISING ARE GREAT.
I RIGHT NOW SOMEBODY WORKS WITH
BUSINESSES BY OFFERING THEIR
EXPERTISE ELECTRICITY AND POWER
MANAGEMENT.
IS HELPFUL FOR THE EMERGING
GREEN TECHNOLOGIES WHICH ARE
USUALLY START UP ENTITIES
WORKING WITH MATT.
AT THE START UPS ARE PURCHASED
BY ANOTHER COMPANY SMUD WOULD BE
ABLE TO REALIZE A RETURN ON THE
VALUE OF THAT EQUITY AND AND IN
TURN HELP OUR RATE PAYERS HERE
IN SACRAMENTO -- THOSE START UPS
I WOULD NEVER BEEN ABLE TO DO SO
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO TO TEAM
UP WITH MUD IN THEIR
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
THIS BILL HAS DUAL BENEFITS OF
ENCOURAGING DEVELOPMENT IN GREEN
TECHNOLOGIES AND AND REACHING
ARE IN BUSINESS CLIMATE GOALS
AND OFFSETTING SOME OF THE RATE
INCREASE IS NECESSARY TO REACH
THESE GOALS.
AGAIN HELPING OUR CUSTOMERS THIS
IS A FAIRNESS ISSUE ALLOWING
SOMEBODY DO WHAT'S WHAT'S YOUR
I. A USE CAN DO.
IN CALIFORNIA ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WITH ME.
IS -- THE CEO OF SMART ARLEN
ORCHARD AS WELL AS SOME OTHER
PARTNERS.
GREAT WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- I AM
ARLEN ORCHARD ON THIS CEO OF
****.
I WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY AND AS OF THE
ASSEMBLYMAN NOTED THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW SOME SMART THE
OPTION. TO HOLD SECURITY OR IN
EQUITY INTEREST IN A CORPORATION
OTHER THAN A STOCK THIS IS THE
SAME MECHANISM CURRENTLY USED
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM.
BUT AS LONG WORKED WITH
COMPANIES ON VARIOUS PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES THAT PROVIDE
INTERNET INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ADDRESS ENERGY AFFORDABILITY
ENERGY EFFICIENCY DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES AND RELIABILITY.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AS
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT WILL BE
NEEDED IN NEW TECHNOLOGIES GREAT
MARTIN -- STATION ENERGY
RESOURCES ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION TO MEET **** AND
CALIFORNIA'S CARBON REDUCTION
AND CLEAN ENERGY GOALS FOR SOME
OF THESE PRODUCTS AND SERVICES
SMUD PROVIDES ACCESS TO ITS
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY.
DEVOTE SUBSTANTIAL STAFF TIME
AND PROVIDES CRITICAL FIELD
TESTING THE COMPANIES THAT WE
PARTNER WITH MEETING CAPITALIZE
ON OUR CONTRIBUTIONS BY
MARKETING THESE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES. TO OTHER UTILITIES AT
A SIGNET SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
PROPERTY -- PROFIT BUT THAT IS
NOT A PROFIT THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
CURRENTLY SHARE AN FOR INSTANT
YOUR INSTANCE YEARS AGO WE
INVESTED TIME AND EFFORT WITH
THE COMPANY TO DEVELOP A
SIGNIFICANT SOFTWARE PRODUCT.
THAT ANALYZES METER DATA TO
COMPARE CUSTOMER ENERGY USAGE
THIS COMPANY WENT PUBLIC IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN SECURING
MORE THAN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING.
WITH NEGOTIATED OR HAVE THE
ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE A EQUITY
INTEREST IN THAT COMPANY THE
COMPANY OUR CUSTOMERS WOULD HAVE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO BENEFIT
FROM THE FINANCIAL RETURN PAID
THIS MUCH. FOR CONTRIBUTION TO
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT PRODUCT
AND SUCCESS OF THAT COMPANY.
WITH THE ENERGY INDUSTRY RAPIDLY
CHANGING CALIFORNIA LEADING THE
WAY THE TIME IS PARTICULARLY
RIGHT FIRST MONTH INVESTMENTS IN
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY TO BE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED.
ESTIMATE IS PLANNING TO SPEND
MORE THAN SIX POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FROM NOW UNTIL TWENTY
FORTY TO ACHIEVE OUR NET ZERO
CARBON EMISSIONS GOAL IS LET
OUTLINED IN OUR INTEGRATED
RESOURCES PLAN.
THESE EXPENDITURES TO MEET OUR
CARBON REDUCTION GOALS WILL
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT RATE
INCREASE SAYS FOR OUR CUSTOMERS
IN THE FUTURE.
THE OPTION FOR SMART TO HOLD THE
SECURITY INTEREST IN COMPANY A
IN A COMPANY UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES
WERE SMART CONTRIBUTES TO THE
SUCCESSFUL COMMERCIALIZATION OF
THE TECHNOLOGIES.
THAT MEETS MODES BUSINESS NEEDS
BENEFIT OUR CUSTOMERS AND
SUPPORT OUR CARBON REDUCTION
GOALS WILL HELP MITIGATE THESE
EXPECTED RATE INCREASES AS ANY
NEW REVENUE WOULD BE REINVESTED
AND SMART OR IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS AND ASK YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M JUST A
NEED TO DO REALLY QUICK
HOUSEKEEPING WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND I'D LIKE TO MOVE THAT --
DIXIE.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE LACKEY LACKEY HERE BLOOM
BURNER HERVE.
RAMOS RAMOS HERE THREE OF US
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT -- WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR WOMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LISA HAGERMAN I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF PROGRAMS AT DPL PARTNERS WE
ARE DOUBLE BOTTOM LINE VENTURE
CAPITAL FIRM.
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO IN PALO
ALTO WE'VE BEEN AROUND FOURTEEN
YEARS AND WE INVEST IN -- START
UPS THAT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE IN VALUE AS WELL AS FOR
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL RETURNS
IN THE SECTORS AND REGIONS IN
WHICH WE INVEST.
AND HAVE -- OF INVESTED SKIP
ANILINE CLEAN ENERGY CLEAN TACK
AND SUSTAINABLE PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES.
OVER THE PAST FOURTEEN YEARS.
D. B. L. SUPPORTS MODES EFFORTS
TO DRIVE INNOVATION AND THE
CLEAN ENERGY SPACE THIS BILL
WILL BRING TO MARKET THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY TO TREAT OUR STATES
CLIMATE AND ENERGY AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY GOALS.
CREATING INCENTIVES FOR
UTILITIES TO WORK WITH NEW
COMPANIES HELPS REDUCE THE RISK
OF NEW COMPANY INVESTMENTS WHICH
WILL ATTRACT MORE INVESTORS AND
CREATE MORE JOBS.
WHEN YOUNG START UPS ARE
PARTNERING WITH UTILITIES AND
OTHERS TO REFINE THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES AND PRODUCTS IT IS
OFTEN DIFFICULT TO AGREE TO
ROYALTY AGREEMENTS?
AS THOSE OFTEN HAMPER FUTURE
GROWTH.
HOWEVER.
THE OPTIONS PROVIDED UNDER THIS
BILL.
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR SMILED
AND START UP COMPANIES TO FORM
STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS THAT
COULD LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
TECHNOLOGICAL AND PRODUCT AREAS.
D. B. L. LOOKS FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
UTILITIES AND OTHERS. TO ADVANCE
THIS BILL AND PROMOTE CLEAN
ENERGY THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THANK YOU THIS IS A CAMPAñA
TIME HOW WITH CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION.
ALSO IN SUPPORT TODD SPECIAL
DISTRICTS PROVIDE ESSENTIAL.
LOCAL SERVICES USUALLY.
A SINGLE SERVICES OR MAYBE A
SMALL BASKET OF SERVICES WHETHER
IT'S FIRE PROTECTION.
FLOOD CONTROL CLEAN WATER OR IN
THIS CASE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
AND THE WAY WE FUNCTION AS WERE
REALLY PROUD OF DELIVERING THESE
QUALITY LOCAL SERVICES.
WITH TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC
ACCOUNTABILITY BEING LIKES MOD.
ELECTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
WE THINK THAT THIS BILL IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED STRIKES
THAT.
GOOD BALANCE BOB PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC TRUST WHILE STILL
ALLOWING SMILED TO MEET ITS
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS.
BOB BEING FLEXIBLE AND AND A BIT
OF URGING MY VOTE THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PATRICK WELCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILIZATION
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL AS
MUCH AS LONG BEEN INNOVATOR IN
ENERGY SPACE AND AB SIX EIGHT
NINE WHILE OTHER CUSTOMERS TO
SHARE IN THE BENEFITS AND HELP
STABILIZE RATES AS THEY MAKE.
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS TO MEET
THE STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
PROF BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SACRAMENTO AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF MERIT THEY'LL STAND
BURKE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NINE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE.
OKAY YEAH WE NEED A MOTION
[inaudible] SEVEN OKAY HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND -- WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A CLOSING STATEMENT.
THANK YOU TO ASK THE ARRIVAL
THIS IS A SMART MEASURE AND ****
HAS ALREADY LOST OUT ON A FEW
MILLION DOLLARS -- WITH THESE
ARRANGEMENTS AND IN THE PAST AND
THIS IS CERTAINLY HELP OUR RATE
PAYERS AND HELP US ACHIEVE OUR
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS FOR
SACRAMENTO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SECRETARY AT THE READY FOR
THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS A MAN
AND A RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON BANKING AND FINANCE.
AGUIAR-CURRY LACKEY NO LACKEY NO
BLOOM.
BURNER HER VAST [inaudible]
RAMOS RAMOS I THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS VOEPEL.
NO WELL.
OF HEALTH NOT VOTING.
THIS IS ITEM [inaudible]
NINE YES.
UNDER HER A BATH HI [inaudible]
OR CALL [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE BILL REMAINS ON CALL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
NEXTEL. NINE FORTY FIVE YES YOU
MAY BEGIN.
YEAH FOR ME AND MY WITNESSES
APPEAR [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR HER
TO PRESENT AB NINE FORTY FIVE AM
ENSURE IT WHICH WOULD ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF THEIR SURPLUS FUNDS
THAT THEY MAY INVEST IN SECURE
FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS CALLED
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS.
THIS BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
AGENCIES DO THAT BUT IT WOULD BE
PERMISSIVE IF IT MAKES FINANCIAL
SENSE FOR THAT AGENCY A CURRENT
LAW PLACES MANY RESTRICTIONS ON
THE TYPE INVESTMENT OF SURPLUS
FUNDS.
FROM LOCAL LOCAL AGENCIES MAY
INVEST IN THOSE RESTRICTIONS
INCLUDE ENSURING THE INVESTMENTS
MUST BE MUST HAVE HIGH LIQUIDITY
AND DO NOT POSE A HIGHER RISK TO
THE LOCAL AGENCY.
THE BILL DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF
THESE RESTRICTIONS IMPORTANT
RESTRICTIONS BUT DOES INCREASE
THE AMOUNT THAT COULD BE USED
FROM AGENCIES SURPLUS FROM 20%.
TO FIFTY A CALIFORNIA IS THE
ONLY STATE IN THE NATION WHICH
HAS SUCH A CAP ON THESE
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS.
WE ARE SANDERS A NEED FOR
CAUTION BUT THIS IS A SMART
MEASURE WHICH ALLOWS OUR LOCALS.
TO INVEST WITH COMMUNITY BANKS
AND CREDIT UNIONS INSTITUTIONS
ARE GOOD EMPLOYERS GOOD FOR THE
COMMUNITIES PROVIDE FINANCIAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE OFTEN TURNED AWAY FROM THE
BIG BANKS.
INCREASING THE CAP WILL MEAN
THAT THESE CUTS COMMUNITY BANKS
WILL HAVE MORE ABILITY TO GIVE
OUT CREDIT FOR THINGS LIKE SMALL
BUSINESS LOANS.
THIS WILL HAVE A DIRECT
MULTIPLIER EFFECT ON OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WITH ME ARE TO A LOCAL ENTITIES --
WORKING ON BANKING ISSUES FOR
MANY YEARS FOR THE SACRAMENTO
AREA STEPHEN FLEMING CO RIVER
CITY BANK AND JAMES BECKWITH.
EXECUTIVE VP FIVE STAR BANK.
OKAY GO AHEAD WITNESSES AND
SPARKLE AT OB THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY ON JAMES BACK WITH THEM
ACTUALLY THE PRESIDENT AND CEO
FIVE STAR BANK.
NO WORRIES THEM SOME WOMEN BOB
I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THAT I WANTED -- TO EXPRESS --
MIGHT USE ABOUT THIS IF I COULD --
THIS BILL ALLOWS SO IT WILL
ALLOW FOR GREATER FLEXIBILITY ON
BEHALF OF THOSE -- TREASURES
MUNICIPAL OFFICERS IN TERMS OF
UTILIZING RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS.
CURRENTLY BOB SPECIAL DISTRICTS
AND MUNICIPALITIES AND COUNTIES
HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COLLATERALIZED.
PUBLIC DEPOSITS WHICH IS A
REQUIREMENT BY LAW WITH THREE
DISTINCT COLLATERAL SOURCES MIND
THAT'S MUCH SECURITIES QUALIFIED
INVESTMENT SECURITIES.
LETTER CREDIT FROM FHL BE OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND RECIPROCAL
DEPOSITS.
WE THANK OUR BY ALLOWING AN
INCREASE BOB FROM THIRTY TO
FIFTY IN REMOVING THE SUNSET
WHICH THIS BILL -- REQUIRES IS A
VERY GOOD THING FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT TO
FOLKS IN THE CAPITAL REGION --
BODY YEAR AGO STEVEN I PUT
TOGETHER A PROGRAM CALLED RISE
RESPONSIBLE INVESTMENTS FOR A
STRONG ECONOMY.
SIMPLY IT WORKS LIKE THIS WE
TAKE MUNICIPAL DEPOSITS OR TO
SPECIAL DISTRICT DEPOSITS ARE
COUNTY DEPOSITS.
IN COLLATERALIZED THEM.
UNDER THE THREE METHODS WHICH I
JUST SHARED WITH YOU.
AND WE AGREED TO TURN AROUND AND
LEND THOSE MONEYS BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. TO DATE WE HAVE
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
OF THOSE TYPES OF DEPOSITS IN IN
OUR INSTITUTIONS AND WE PLAN TO
OUT ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION BACK
INTO OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
SO WE BELIEVE.
THAT THIS INCREASE IN ALLOWING A
GREATER USE OF RECIPROCAL
DEPOSITS.
WILL ALLOW FOR GREATER USE OF OF
LOCAL DEPOSITS PLACED IN LOCAL
COMMUNITY BANKS.
THIS IS NOT A REQUIREMENT THIS
IS ABSOLUTELY DISCRETIONARY ON
BEHALF OF THE THE TREASURES IN
THE NESTLE PAUL OFFICERS THEY
CAN UTILIZE ANY -- THREE
COLLATERAL PULLS IF YOU WILL.
AND WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD
POLICY FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH IN
OUR COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- THANKS JAMES AND
THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY -- AS IN THE KID I'M
STEVE FLEMING PRESIDENT RIVER
CITY BANK BASED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AB NINE FORTY FIVE IS IMPORTANT
TO US I'LL BE AT WE ALL AT LEAST --
WEEK WE ON THE BANKING SIDE WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S A BIT OF A A
NERDY GEEKY -- BANKING KIND OF
KIND OF BILL -- BUT STILL NEVER
LESS IMPORTANT TO US -- RIVER
CITY BANK.
IN -- NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE
WE'RE THE LARGEST BANK IN IN
SACRAMENTO -- BUT WERE
RELATIVELY SMALL COMPARED TO THE
NAME BRAND NATIONAL BANKS THAT
JUST YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH.
WHERE WESTERNERS A COMMUNITY
BANK JUST LIKE FIVE STAR BANK --
WHICH MEANS THAT WE HAVE A A
NEAR OR GEOGRAPHIC FOCUS FOR OUR
OUR TARGET CUSTOMERS THEN THE
THE LARGEST BANKS IN OUR CASE IT
HAPPENS TO BE CUSTOMERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
PUBLIC SECTOR ENTITIES ARE
IMPORTANT. FOR US IN TERMS OF
OUR TARGET MARKET -- WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF THE FACT THAT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN JUST LAST YEAR
THE CITY DAVIS I MADE A DECISION --
TO MOVE THEIR BANKING
RELATIONSHIP TO RIVER CITY BANK
FROM ONE OF THE NATIONAL BANKS
WHOSE NAME YOU YOU YOU WILL SEE
ON THE NEWS QUITE OFTEN -- PROPS
MORE IMPORTANT MORE IMPORTANTLY
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THE FACT
THAT WE ARE THE THE BANK -- THE
LEADING BANK IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ENTITIES CREATED
UNDER THE COMMUNITY CHOICE
AGGREGATION LEGISLATION.
WE BANK FIFTEEN OF THE TWENTY CC
ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE WHOSE
MANDATE REALLY IS TO DELIVER A
HIGHER CONTENT TO OF CLEAN
ENERGY -- FOR US WHICH WE WE ALL
KNOW IS IMPORTANT AND ALSO --
REDUCE PRICES FOR FOR RATEPAYERS
SO WE'RE PROUD OF OUR
ASSOCIATION WITH THOSE PUBLIC
SECTOR ENTITIES.
AB NINE FORTY FIVE IS -- IS A
GOOD DEAL FOR OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
IN THERE FOR PUBLIC POLICY --
AND IT'S A GOOD DEAL FOR OUR
BANKS IT'S A GOOD DEAL FOR THE
PUBLIC SECTOR -- BECAUSE WE CAN
PAY A HIGHER RATE OF INTEREST ON
THOSE DEPOSITS -- WHICH OF
COURSE ARE OUR CUSTOMERS
APPRECIATE THOSE DEPOSITS IS
JAMES NOTED CAN BE MAINTAINED
AND LIQUID ACCOUNTS -- SO THE
TREASURES HAVE COMPLETE CONTROL
OVER THE LIQUIDITY OF THEIR
INVESTMENTS -- THEY ALSO ARE
1100% AT THE I. C. INSURED SO
THERE'S NO SAFETY ISSUES THERE --
AND IT ALLOWS US TO LEND MORE
MONEY OUT -- WITHOUT HAVING TO
COLLATERALIZED THOSE DEPOSITS WE
HAVE MORE ABILITY TO LEND NINETY
INTO OUR COMMUNITIES WHICH
PROMOTES ECONOMIC GROWTH.
AND JOB CREATION SO FOR THOSE
REASONS -- WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KEVIN
GOLD WITH THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE SPONSOR
OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING UP
FOR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
SPENDING TIME CONSIDERING THIS
MEASURE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
ARTICLE THAT'S THE NUMBER OF
HAVE THE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BANKING NETWORK WE
ALSO THINK ALSO BRINGS FORWARD
AND ASKED FOR AYE VOTE.
ROBERT WILSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
OKAY THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER TERRY
MEMBERS KAREN LAYING OFF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
TREASURER'S AND TAX COLLECTORS.
TO BE CLEAR THE COUNTY
TREASURER'S.
HAVE NOT ASKED FOR THIS
LEGISLATION AND THEY DID NOT
FIND THAT THE CAP NEEDS TO BE
RAISED NONE OF THEIR MEMBERS ARE
COMPLAINING THAT THE 30% CAP.
IS RESTRICTING THEIR ABILITY TO
INVEST WITH THESE BANKS.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT TYING UP
50% OF THE COUNTY POOL.
WITH THE SURPLUS FUNDS BEING
HALF ABOUT HALF ON A DAILY BASIS
OF THE SCHOOLS DOLLARS IN AN
INSTRUMENT THAT MAY OR MAY NOT
BE LIKE WITH THE THERE'S A
COUPLE DIFFERENT TYPES THAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF CONCERNS
WITH ALLOWING THAT INSTRUMENT AT
50% OF THE SURPLUS BECAUSE
WHAT'S CONSIDERED SURPLUS MAY
ACTUALLY BE.
CAPITAL DOLLARS FIRST SCHOOLS
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT AND THEY'RE
JUST THE BILLS ARE DUE YET SO.
IF A BILL IS DUE AND THOSE FUNDS
ARE NOT READILY AVAILABLE IN THE
PUTS PRESSURE ON OTHER POOL
PARTICIPANTS AS IDENTIFIED IN
THE ANALYSIS.
SO WE'RE FINE WITH ELIMINATING
THE SUNSET.
BUT AGAIN THIS IS THE COUNTY
TREASURER'S WHO ARE THE TARGET
OF THIS BILL ARE NOT IDENTIFYING
A PROBLEM WITH THE CURRENT CAP.
THAT THE RESTRICTIONS ON A LOT
EXIST BECAUSE ORANGE COUNTY WENT
BANKRUPT AND WE ARE REQUIRED TO
ABIDE BY IT VERY SPECIFIC
INVESTMENT CRITERIA WE NEED TO
SPREAD THE RISK WE SHOULD NOT BE
CONCENTRATING IT AND WE DON'T
REALLY SEE HOW WE CAN CONTINUE
TO COMPLY WITH.
THE LAW AS IT RELATES TO
SPREADING THE RISK.
OF BY PUTTING 50% OF THE POLLING
ONE THING SO FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED TO
REMOVE THE CAP FOR FOR WITH
EVERY MOVE THAT I'D DEADLINE FOR
THE SUNSET WERE FINE WITH THAT.
ON THE PROGRAM SEEMS TO BE
WORKING BUT AGAIN THERE'S NO
DEMAND FOR THIS INCREASE AND WE
VIEW IT AS BEING CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER PARTS OF THEIR STATUTORY
MANDATE SO WITH THAT WE ASK FOR
YOUR PUT THEM WITH AMENDED --
MOTION THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTION TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
GOOD. TO THE LAST WITNESS NOW.
WHEN I WAS MAYOR OF THE CITY?
OUR CITY AND I'VE ALSO OBSERVE
THE COUNTIES COULD PICK.
MANY DIFFERENT -- FUNDS TO BE.
STASH THEIR MONEY.
SOME ARE MORE LIKE MONEY MARKET
FUNDS OTHERS ARE LIKE THIS.
SO.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT YOUR
CONCERN IS WHEN YOU HAVE FREEDOM
OF CHOICE OVER SO MANY DIFFERENT
INVESTMENT OPPORTUNITIES OR JUST
SIMPLY TRYING TO PRESERVE YOUR
CAPITAL.
AT THE THE PROMISE OF THE
MEASURE IS 50% IN ONE OF
ANYTHING THERE'S I CAN PROMISE
YOU THERE'S NOT 50% OF THE
COUNTY TREASURY.
AND ANY OF THE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES INVESTED IN ONE THING
AND 30% SEEMS.
A PRETTY HEALTHY NUMBER OF THIS
THAT THE SURPLUS DOLLARS 50%
COULD GET INTO YOU COULD GET
INTO REAL TROUBLE.
AND BECOME ILLIQUID UNDER THE
CITY REQUIREMENTS THAT WE HAVE
RELATED.
TO AFTER ORANGE COUNTY WENT
BANKRUPT IT'S SAFETY FIRST THE
RETURN OF PRINCIPLE NOT RETURN
ON PRINCIPLE.
AND THEN LIQUIDITY AND THEN
YOU'LL NOT BE THE THIRD THING
YOU CONSIDER BUT LIQUIDITY MUST
BE READILY AVAILABLE AND THE 50%
OF THE DOLLARS ARE INVESTED IN
ONE THING.
IT BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT -- TO
TO ACCESS IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
THE INSTRUMENT IS.
MR TERROR THE FORCE TO COME AS
PLEASE.
SO MY COMMENT TO THAT IS THEY
ALL THE ENTITIES HAVE A WIDE
VARIETY WHERE THEY WANT TO PUT
THEIR MONEY AND FREEDOM OF
CHOICE.
SO.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S 50% IN ONE
FUND.
HEY MAYBE YOU DON'T WANT TO PUT.
YOUR MONEY IN THAT ONE FUN.
BUT YOU HAVE A MUCH WIDER CHOICE
IN ALL SORTS OF OTHER FUNDS
WHICH I PERSONALLY WOULD FEEL
VERY COMFORTABLE WITH A FIVE AS
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR OR ANY OTHER
LEADER MAKING THOSE DECISIONS --
SO THAT'S MY COMMENT TO YOU TO
THE AUTHOR -- I THINK THIS IS A
WONDERFUL BILL.
AND I THINK IT HELPS BRING
CALIFORNIA UP.
TO THE LEVELS INTERESTS UNITED
STATES [inaudible]
END NEXT.
SESSION I WOULD LIKE TO SEE 75%
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
BABY STEPS [inaudible]
OKAY.
NO THE QUESTIONS.
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO ANNOUNCE TO
THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO BE.
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR EVEN THOUGH
SHE'S NOT HERE YES.
OKAY YOU RECALLS.
YES THANK YOU IT AND MAYBE
MISTER VOEPEL LIKE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL AWESOME AND YES
SIR OF YEAH RESERVE.
YES AND AGAIN I I APPRECIATE THE
THE CONCERN BUT THIS IS --
PERMISSIVE AS WE STATE IN THE
END THERE ARE NUMBER OF
RESTRICTIONS ARE IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THESE ARE A RISKY
INVESTMENTS I THINK THIS IS A A
REASONED RESPONSE IN ADDITION.
TO EXTEND THE SUNSET TO
MODERNIZE THIS POLICY TO PUT US
IN LINE WITH OTHER STATES
THROUGHOUT THE NATION ASK YOUR
EYE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALL I GUESS WE NEED A BUDGET
FIRST.
NOW WE'RE READY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCE AGUIAR-CURRY
LACKEY HI LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER **** BACK.
BURNER HER ABOUT THAT I RAMOS.
RAMOS I THREE OF US THREE OF US
I ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
[inaudible]
HI. SIX ZERO MEASURES OUT SIX
ZERO GRADUATION.
OKAY WE'LL LET THE CALL AND SB.
SIX EIGHTY NINE CURRENT VOTE IS.
TWO TO ONE AGUIAR-CURRY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
OKAY MISTER CHAIR THERE'S A
POINT OF ORDER -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA DID PRESENT ON THE
HIS FIRST BILL AND THERE WAS NOT
A MOTION ON THAT SO IS IT IN
ORDER TO MAKE A MOTION TO MOVE
THAT BILL NOW.
YES NO WE CAN DO THAT CERTAINLY
THANK YOU MOVE THE BILL MEDINA
BILL SECOND.
THE MOTION ON ITEM FOR A. B.
FORTY FIVE MEDINA IS TO PASS AND
MAY REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
AGUIAR-CURRY LACKEY NO LACKEY NO
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS.
I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
[inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL NO [inaudible]
HEALTH [inaudible]
NEEDS.
OKAY THAT BILL -- REMAINS OUT
COLLEGE ONE MORE VOTE.
OKAY LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
YOUR NINE ANNOUNCE WHAT ITEMS
THOSE ARE.
THE SIX THIRTY TWO WE HAVE ITEM.
SIX EIGHT I AM EIGHT SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO AND ITEM TWELVE
A. B..
TEN EIGHTY FOUR THE MOTION
MOTION [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY.
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HERVE.
BURNER BURNER HER ABOUT FIVE
RAMOS.
GRAHAM RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH ROBERT RIVAS
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL I YEAH SIX ZERO DAYS.
CONTIGUOUS OUT.
SIX ZERO MR FOR FRIDAY NIGHT
OKAY WILL HAVE ITEM NINETEEN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
FOR I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WAS START OFF BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK YOU IN YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY OFFICE.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO EST
DISTRICT BILL THAT WOULD PROVIDE
OUR COMMUNITY WITH MUCH NEEDED
TOOLS. TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TO AUTHORIZE
CITY OF MEANT TO GET TO TRANSFER
A GOVERNMENT WE OWN THE
GOVERNMENT OWNED PROPERTY FOR
LESS THAN MARKET VALUE TO A
LOCAL NONPROFIT THAT.
PROVIDES RESOURCES TO
HOMELESSNESS AND LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
AS YOU MAY KNOW CALIFORNIA
STRUGGLING TO CONFRONT THE
HOMELESS CRISIS MANTECA AND
LOCAL NONPROFITS OR DO THEY DO
ALL THEY CAN TO ADDRESS THIS.
ONE NONPROFIT IN MY DISTRICT
TOOK ADVANTAGE OF THIS VACANT
PROPERTY MENTIONED IN THE BILL.
TO SET UP A TEMPORARY RESOURCE
CENTER FOR HOME FOR FOR HOMELESS
THIS.
JUST TWENTY FIVE DAYS A CENTER
WAS OPENED THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX PEOPLE RECEIVE SERVICES.
AND THERE'LL BE A TWENTY THREE
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET INCLUDING
THREE CHILDREN.
THE CENTRAL LOCATION THIS
BUILDING PROVED TO BE OF GREAT
VALUE TO THEIR EFFORTS HOWEVER
BECAUSE OF ALREADY A DISSOLUTION
AGING PROPERTY MUST BE SOLD AT
AUCTION.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
PROVIDE MAN TAKEN OPPORTUNITY
UTILIZE THE BUILDING.
AS OTHERWISE SET VACANT FOR
NEARLY FIFTEEN YEARS TO BETTER
PROVIDE CRITICAL RESOURCES TO
THE HOMELESS.
HERE WITH ME TEST BY SUPPORT THE
BILL AND ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS ARE MAYOR OF ANTIQUE
OF THE DRINK INTO AND
COUNCILMEMBER GERRY'S THING
[inaudible]
JOHN.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE -- GARY
SAYING.
CITY COUNCILMAN PRESIDIUM ANTICA
I PORT APPEAR BEFORE YOU THIS
COMMITTEE TO SPEAK BEHALF OF
CITY OF MANTECA.
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO WE WISH.
TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY MAN HE
FLOOR AND ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
CONSIDERING THIS LEGISLATION --
THE PROBLEM THAT HOMELESSNESS IS
WELL DOCUMENTED IN OUR COMMUNITY
IN THE SOME LOOKING COUNTY IN
CALIFORNIA AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATION.
OFFICIAL POINT OF COUNT HAVE
SHOWN THE STEADY CLIMBING ON
SHELTER HOMELESS INDIIDUALS
ENMITY CA SINCE.
TWENTY ELEVEN AND WE KNOW IT.
WE NOW HOUSE THE SECOND MOST AND
SHELTERED INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
COUNTY.
FURTHERMORE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK WITH THE
HOMELESS POPULATION MAINTAINED
THAT THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THE CITY
IS SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER.
DUE TO THE DIFFICULTY IN
ACCURATELY COUNTING HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
A MAN TAKE OUR COUNCIL HAS
COMMITTED RESOURCES TO FIND TWO
POSITIONS.
IN OUR POLICE DEPARTMENT TO
PERFORM DIRECT OUT REGION
REFERRALS TO SERVICE PROVIDERS
TO HELP THESE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
BUT WE MUST DO MORE.
WHAT WE LACK IN IS A FACILITY TO
CO LOCATE THE SUPPORT AGENCIES
AND THE SERVICE PROVIDERS? TO
EFFECTIVELY COORDINATE DELIVERY
OF SERVICES TO OUR HOMELESS
NEIGHBORS.
IN THEIR TIME OF GREATEST NEED.
UNDER AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO
WHERE REQUESTING THAT A PROPERLY
FORMALLY OWNED BY OUR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
BE CONVERTED INTO A HOMELESS
SERVICE FACILITY RATHER THAN
BEING SOLD AT AUCTION.
MY TICKET COUNCIL ACTUALLY HAS
PASSED A RESOLUTION ON APRIL
SECOND TO DO THIS VERY THING.
WE UNDERSTAND THIS LESS
LEGISLATION IF APPROVED MAY
REQUIRE REASONABLE CONDITION AND
TIME LINES FOR FOUR MORE MINUTES.
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE HOMELESS
ISSUE CANNOT BE IGNORED.
WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT FOR OUR
COMMUNITY BASED APPROACH BY
VOTING IN FAVOR OF AB.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE OF BEN CAN'T
TO MAYOR OF THE CITY OF ANTICA --
I CAMPAIGNED FOR MAYOR FOR ABOUT
TEN YEARS FINALLY GOT ELECTED ON
THE PREMISE THAT.
WE WERE GOING TO DO SOMETHING
WITH THE HOMELESS.
I HAD MY EYE ON THIS BUILDING.
FOR ALL WELL OVER THE PERIOD OF
TIME AND UNFORTUNATELY RDA
TERMINATED -- BUT NOW THAT I'M
ELECTED AND WITH THE HELP OF THE
COUNCIL -- WE ARE FINALLY GOING
TO DO SOMETHING.
WITH OUR GROWING -- HOMELESS
POPULATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER MEMBERS --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HELLO FRANK SAUNA FOUNDER OF
INNER CITY ACTION I SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YOU.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THOSE LOOK LIKE WE HAVE ANY OKAY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ZERO I JUST WANNA SAY THAT --
MANTECA IS TO BE CONGRATULATED
FOR HAVING A PROACTIVE APPROACH
ON HOMELESSNESS SO GREATLY
APPRECIATED AND I LOOK TO MAKE
THE MOTION.
THANK AND CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
THANKS SO MUCH.
THEY DO HAVE A MOTION OR SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION OR JUST A
SECOND [inaudible]
OKAY.
MY APOLOGIES WE HAVE A MOTION TO
SECOND -- AUTHOR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO HAVE A CLOSING STATEMENT JUST
RESPECT LAST RIVAL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY SECTOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
AGUIAR-CURRY LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE BLOOM BLOOM AYE BOERNER
HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT SIX ZERO THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU.
RUNNING LATE.
OKAY I'D OF FIFTEEN IS OF
EVEREST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE OF THE STAFF FOR
ALL THE WORK.
THEY PUT INTO THIS BILL TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN WHICH DISSOLVES THE
EXISTING -- TRANCE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY AND REORGANIZES IT IS
ON THE TRANCE SPECIAL TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
I'M A TRANS JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IS THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
AGENCY FORMED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX AND OFFERS PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION THROUGHOUT THE
SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY. TO CITIES
OF MY DISTRICT INCLUDING COLTON
FONTANA GRANT TERRACE RIALTO IN
SAN BERNADINO AS WELL AS
UNINCORPORATED AREAS WITHIN THE
COUNTY.
CURRENTLY THE DISTRICT IS
PLANNING TO EXPAND SERVICES. TO
FACILITATE THE REDLANDS
PASSENGER RAIL PROJECT AND
ADVANCE TO REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT DESIGNED
TO CONNECT [inaudible]
RESIDENTS.
BUSINESSES AND VISITORS TO
DESTINATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
REGION.
IN ADDITION THE PROJECT HAS
RECEIVED A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
GRANT TO MAKE IT THE FIRST.
BATTERY OPERATED ZERO EMISSION
PASSENGER TRAIN IN NORTH AMERICA.
IN ORDER TO FACILITATE THE
OPERATION OF THIS PROJECT
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN SIMPLY
REORGANIZES THE OMNITRANS JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY INTO ON THE
TRANS SPECIAL TRANSIT DISTRICT.
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY OR TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THE NEW
STRUCTURE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE SAME BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND
ASSUME ALL RIGHTS OBLIGATIONS
AND LIABILITIES.
OF THE EXISTING JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
FACILITATE THE TRANSITION THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH OTHER PUBLIC
TRANSIT DISTRICT REFORMS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE WITH ALL PARTIES.
AS THIS BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
HERE TO TESTIFYING WITH ME.
ON BEHALF OF THIS BILL IS CYRUS
DEVERS.
ON BEHALF OF THEM THE CHANCE.
I THANK YOU SIR IS DIVERSE FOR
BY BEST BESTING KRIEGER
REPRESENTING OMNITRANS THE
SPONSOR AS THE FROM THE HELP
THEM DRAFT THE BILL OF THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS AND BY THE OPPOSITION
AS YOU SAW.
WHEN WE REACH OUT TO DRAFT IT
LOOK FOR LANGUAGE TO FATHER WE
REACH TO THE MOST RECENT TRANSIT
DISTRICT ACT FOR REASONS NO ONE
CAN EXPLAIN THESE ISSUES WERE
NOT ADDRESSED IN THAT ACT AND SO
WOULD WEWOULD LOOK FOR A MODEL
THEY WERE SIMPLY -- WEREN'T
TRANSFERRED OVER THAT IS THE
SOME EXPLANATION FOR WHY THESE
ISSUES RAISING HOUSES WERE NOT
ADDRESSED IN THE INTRODUCED
REGION WE HAVE NO TROUBLE
WHATSOEVER ADDRESSING THE ISSUES
RAISED IN ANALYSIS HE AND CAN
ABSOLUTELY COMMIT TO WORKING
THINGS OUT WITH.
BOTH LAUGH CO AND THE
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION.
THE ONLY THING WE MIGHT SAY IS
THAT AS WITH OUR LANGUAGE THAT
IS SOMETIMES MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS OLD TO HAVE AN EYE TOWARDS
MODERNIZING IT.
SO SOMETIMES YOU'LL SEE
REFERENCES TO CIRCULATION IN A
NEWSPAPER OR A SEALED BID OR
CASHIER'S CHECK THE REALITY IS
PEOPLE THAT USE THESE THINGS IN
MARK WE USE PLANET BIDS WE USE
ELECTRONIC TRANSFER SO.
IF THERE'S ANYTHING WE MIGHT
WANT TO MODERNIZE LANGUAGE BUT
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO SIRIUS OKAY NOW WITNESSES
NOT POSITION [inaudible]
EXPRESS ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TAUGHT BLOOM SIGN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION -- AS CYRUS'S THAT
HAD MENTIONED THE SPONSORS HAD
MENTIONED -- IT IS STANDARD IN
THESE IN TRANSIT DISTRICT
AUTHORIZATIONS TO HAVE SOME
OUTLINING OF HOW CONTRACTS ARE
HANDLED A WE'VE SUGGESTED
LANGUAGE -- TO THE AUTHOR AND
AND AND TO THE TO THE SUPPORTERS
AS WELL SO -- WITH THAT WE WE
ARE TECHNICALLY A OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION SHOULD THE
AMENDMENT BE ADOPTED WE REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR ON THIS
BILL -- NOT SURE PROBABLY ARMY
TRANSIT BE ANSWERING THAT IS A
PROVIDES FOR A PROCESS FOR THE
ANNEXATION DETACHMENT TERRITORY
TO AND FROM THE DISTRICT.
ISN'T THAT A LAUGH GO PROCESS
AND AND HAVE WE REACHED OUT TO
THE LOCAL LEFT GO TO SEE OF THAT
PROCESS WOULD BE DONE AT THAT
AREA.
IT IS WE HAVE AND WE COPY THAT
LANGUAGE FROM A FORMER STATUTE.
THINKING THAT WE WERE CONFORMING
TO STANDARD PRACTICE WE IN FACT
WILL WORK WITH LASKO AND WE HAVE
NO PROBLEMS OF CLASSICAL BEING
IN CHARGE OF ANNEXATIONS AND
ATTACHMENTS SO WORKING WITH
LAUGHTER SO THEN YOU WOULD BE
PUTTING FORWARD AN APPLICATION --
TO CREATE THIS PAIR OF INFLUENCE
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA YOU KNOW
I MEAN I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON ALL
LAUGHED -- PROCEDURES BUT IF
THAT'S APPROPRIATE FOR LAUGHTER
THAN ABSOLUTELY.
NOT SURE OF THE THE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THERE IS LOOKING AT
THAT AND FORMING THE JP AND WE
SAT ON THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AN
OMNI TRANS.
AND KNOWING THE INTERACTIONS OF
THE RAIL REDLANDS IT'S THERE.
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL THAT LAUGH GOING ALL
THOSE RESOURCES ARE BEING
EXHAUSTED BEFORE WE MOVE FORWARD --
AND IMPLEMENT SOMETHING TO TAKE
IT AWAY FROM THAT AUTHORITY
THAT'S ALREADY GIVEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
SO YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE GONNA BE
WORKING WITH A LAUGH GO TO
CREATE THIS PAIR OF INFLUENCES
SERIN RUNNING THROUGH THEM FOR
ANY ANNEXATION.
WHEN I SAY WORKING WITH LAP
QUITE PUT THAT IN QUOTES WE WE
WILL ACCEPT WHATEVER IT LAUGH CO
THINKS IS APPROPRIATE THANK?
WITHOUT A DOUBT THAT'S IMPORTANT
PARTNER IN THIS STUFF.
THE SCHOOL HAD.
SO TO MY NEIGHBOR THE AUTHOR --
SO YOU'RE WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
CONTRACTORS [inaudible]
AMENDMENT.
I'M WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE OFFERED BY
THE COMMITTEE.
AND I THINK THAT WE WILL
FINALIZE THE LANGUAGE WITH THE
CONTRACTOR I DON'T SEE ANY
PROBLEMS ESPECIALLY WITH OUR
SPONSORS -- SAYING THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
WORK ON I DON'T SEE ANY PROBLEM --
THANK YOU I WOULD CERTAINLY IT'S
A BILL THAT CAN BE BROUGHT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE IF FOR SOME
REASON THE CONTRACTORS OF
ASSOCIATION SAYS THAT WE DID NOT --
TO HONOR OR DID OKAY.
I WAS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN I WAS
OPPOSED BY THE GATE ON THIS BUT
IF MY NEIGHBOR VOUCHES FART THAT
I'M THERE.
THANK A NEIGHBOR.
CAN OTHER QUESTIONS.
FELLOWSHIP.
THE BILL [inaudible]
OKAY.
SECRETARY THINK READY FOR THE
LOW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
TRANSPORTATION AGUIAR-CURRY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING LACKEY NOT
VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM IRA BURNER HARDBACK.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US
[inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL HI.
BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU [inaudible]
IN [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'RE GONNA LET THE CALL FIRST
ON ITEM FOR AB.
FOR EIGHTY FIVE CURRENT VOTE IS
[inaudible]
FOR TO TO AGUIAR-CURRY ROBERT
REAVIS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVERSIDE.
THANK YOU TO MEASURES OUT.
FIVE TO TWO NOW ITEM NINE AB.
SIX EIGHTY NINE CURRENT VOTE IS.
FOUR TO ONE AGUIAR-CURRY
[inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS [inaudible]
ROBERT RIVERSIDE.
THE MEASURES OUT ALSO
.
FIVE TO ONE OKAY ITEM SIX WE NOW
HAVE A SOME WOMEN.
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AB.
FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IS OUT ONE
ON PAGE THREE OF THE ANALYSIS
WHICH CLARIFIES THE AUTHORITY --
THAT THIS BILL CREATES IS
PERMISSIVE.
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH CREATES A
NARROW EXEMPTION FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY TO SELL
DEED RESTRICTED LAND TO ELIGIBLE
LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS AND
PROVIDES THE NECESSARY HOUSING
TO THOSE IN NEED.
CURRENT LAW PREVENTS SINGLE
FAMILY LOTS FROM BEING
SUBDIVIDED HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
MONTEREY BAY HAS WORKED WITH THE
CITY OF SANTA CRUZ SINCE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE TO BUILD EIGHTY
USE THAT ARE OWNER OCCUPIED.
AND STRUCTURES THE OWNERSHIP SO
THAT THE LAND IS HELD JOINTLY BY
THE TO HOMEOWNERS AS TENANTS IN
COMMON.
AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN QUOTA
PHYSIS PROGRAM WITH THIS
PURCHASE A SPECIFIC EXEMPTION
FOR ORGANIZATIONS LIKE HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY IN ORDER TO SERVE
TWICE AS MANY FAMILIES ON THE
SINGLE FAMILY LOTS OF THEY HAVE
ACCESS.
TO SO THE MODEL OF THAT HABITAT
USES -- IT IS A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH CITIES AND THIS
ALLOWS SET IN THE MIDST OF OUR
HOUSING CRISIS WE CAN USE ALL
THE LAND THAT'S AVAILABLE WITH
WILLING HOMEOWNERS.
AND BUILDERS -- TO HOUSE ARE
VULNERABLE POPULATION AB FIVE
EIGHTY SEVEN WILL ENSURE THAT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD
INCREASED ABILITY FOR FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DAVID FOSTER HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY SANTA CRUZ MONTEREY BAY
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
K. BEFORE HE BEGINS -- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
OBJECTION. FOR OUR GENTLEMAN
HERE TO USE A PROP.
THANK YOU OKAY YOU MAY I'M I'M
YOU STILL CITY COUNCIL HERE AND
THEN YOU GOT TO BRING YOUR PETS
SO CATCHERS -- I'M DAVID FOSTER
WITH HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
MONTEREY BAY WE'RE CELEBRATING
OUR THIRTIETH ANNIVERSARY
SERVING SANTA CRUZ AND MODERATE
COUNTIES -- STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE WE STARTED
BUILDING.
PARTNERING WITH THE CITY OF
SANTA CRUZ TO BUILD ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS ANYTIME WE HAD A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME A LOT TO
BUILD ON AND WHAT IT DID WAS IT
OPENED UP THE DOOR.
TO BUILDING TWICE AS MANY HOMES.
ON ON ANY GIVEN PARCEL AND AND
IT ALLOWED US ALSO TO SERVE
SMALLER.
FAMILIES A WE'VE GOT A LOT OF A
SINGLE AND AND TO CARRY IT -- TO
TO HOME A TWO PERSON HOUSEHOLDS
NOW THAT CAN'T BE SERVED WITH
THE THREE OR FOUR BEDROOM HOUSE
ANYMORE.
THIS OPEN THE DOOR TO
HOMEOWNERSHIP FOR THEM AND SO
ALTOGETHER WE BUILT EIGHT HOMES
FOR OF THEM OVER A DISS AND FOUR
OF THEM THEM BEING THE MAIN
HOMES.
AND ALTHOUGH IT'S STRANGE TO
COME WITH A BILL OF PROPOSED SO
WE ARE.
ACTUALLY HAVE A TRACK RECORD
ALREADY OF EIGHT HOMES -- THREE
OF THEM HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN SOLD
BACK TO HABITAT WE FIX THEM UP
AND SOLD THEM TO NEW FAMILIES --
WHAT'S NICE ABOUT THE PROGRAM IS
IT OFFERS PERMANENT
AFFORDABILITY FOR THOSE HOMES NO
MATTER HOW MANY TIMES THEY
TRANSFER BACK AND FORTH -- SO
HOW BOTH FOR OUR COUNTY AND FOR
BUTTE COUNTY NOW WE HAVE SITES
AVAILABLE TO DO THIS AGAIN AND
WE'D LIKE TO HAVE.
A WITH THIS BILL IN PLACE THAT
WILL ALLOW US TO TO BUILD SOME
EXCESS REBELLING UNITS I THINK
ACROSS THE THE COUNTRY OR ACROSS
THE STATE NOW -- LOCAL AND STATE
ORDINANCES ARE ENCOURAGING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A TO USE AND THIS
WILL OPEN THE DOOR FOR SOME OF
THOSE UNITS TO BE -- PERMANENTLY
AFFORDABLE WITH HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
I THINK MISTER KEITH DONE HERE
ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE AUTHOR AND THESE INNOVATIVE
EFFORTS THAT TRY TO LOOK AT
CREATIVE WAYS TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR OUR
CITIZENS I THINK EIGHTY USES A
NATURAL WAY TO DO THAT IT'S
AFFORDABLE AND THIS MAKES A LOT.
OF SINCE MOVING FOR FOR
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SAYS IN MATTER NOT LIGHT HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN BE IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. FOR FOR MY WOULD LIKE
TO THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD LAST YEAR
FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS WHEN I
WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL AN
INSIDIOUS WE TRIED OUR BEST TO
DO THIS.
AND IT WAS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE SO
THE FAR REACHING CONSEQUENCES
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA'S
CENTRAL COAST OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILL BE GREAT WITH
THIS BILL.
AND I WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT IT
WOULD LIKE TO BE.
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THERE WERE MOTION -- FROM COME
LOW OF WHO TO HIM THERE FROM
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
MISTER LUCKY.
CLOSING STATEMENT.
JUST THE OTHER -- WAY THAT THIS
CAN BE USES THAT NONPROFIT
HOUSING DEVELOPERS COULD RETAIN
OWNERSHIP OF THE EIGHTY YOU
UNDER THIS AND RENTED AS A
PORTABLE UNIT.
SO IT GETS A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY
TO LOCALITIES TO FIGURE TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEIR THEIR DEVELOPERS ARE
NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS AND THE
COMMUNITIES AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
YOUR OFFER TO TO COUGH -- AND I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANKS WE ALWAYS HAVE A CREATIVE
SOLUTION YOU NEVER FAIL ME --
ALWAYS SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY
THANK YOU -- SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
FROM ASIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
MEASURES OUT SEVEN ZERO
REGULATIONS VERY MUCH I SEE NO
OTHER PRESENTERS RIGHT NOW AND
THE SOMEONE MEMBER BLOOM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO DO YOUR BILL.
SHALL I START WITH AB.
EIGHT EIGHT ONE SINCE WE'RE ON
THE TOPIC OF EIGHTY USE OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SERVE WHY DON'T YOU
GO AHEAD [inaudible]
HELLO.
WELL ALL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
THAT AT A FIVE YEAR SUNSET TO
THE OWNER OCCUPANCY PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL AND AS YOU ALL KNOW
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS ARE AN
INNOVATIVE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OPTIONS FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THOUSANDS
HAVE BEEN BUILT AROUND THE STATE --
TO OR PERMITTED AROUND THE STATE
AND THIS IS AS A RESULT OF OUR
LEGISLATION SO WE SHOULD BE --
GRATEFUL -- FOR US SOMETHING
THAT HAS RESULTED IN SO MANY
UNITS -- NOT ALL OF OUR
LEGISLATION DOES THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE SOME
BARRIERS TO EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION THAT STILL REMAIN
AND A. B. EIGHT EIGHT ONE SIX
REDUCE THOSE BY.
UPDATING AND CLARIFYING THE
STATUTE THEM.
THE MEASURE DOES A FEW THINGS
FIRST IT CLARIFIES SEVERAL
DEFINITIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING THE DEFINITION OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT.
AND EIGHTY IS DISTANCE FROM
TRANSIT ON THE TYPES OF EXISTING
STRUCTURES THE CAN BE CONVERTED
TO EIGHTY YEARS.
SECONDLY IT REMOVES PROVISIONS
THAT HAVE GIVEN CITIES.
SOME -- A REASONABLY BROAD
DISCRETION FOR DENYING EIGHTY
YOU PERMITS AND FINALLY IT
REMOVES THE OWNER OCCUPANCY
REQUIREMENT A IN THE EXISTING
STATUTE WHICH SUBJECTS EIGHTY
YEARS TO REQUIREMENT THAT IS NOT
EXIST FOR ANY OTHER.
KIND OF HOUSING AND COULD RESULT
IN EIGHTY IS BEING DEMOLISHED.
THAT CREATES A LONG TERM
UNCERTAINTY AROUND A UNITS
FUTURE AFTER IT HAS BEEN BUILT.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AT A
FIVE YEAR SUNSET TO OWNER
OCCUPANCY PROVISIONS SET.
UP TO GET THE LEGISLATURE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
IMPACT OF READ THAT -- REMOVING
THE LANGUAGE MIGHT HAVE --
EIGHTY IS CAN HELP US ADDRESS
THE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND AB
EIGHT EIGHT ONE WILL HELP.
EIGHTY IS REALIZE THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WITH ME IS LUIS
MARATHI ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
EMB.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON AB -- EIGHT EIGHT ONE
SINCE THE LEGISLATURE TOOK
ACTION ON EIGHTY IS AN EFFECTIVE.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN A LOS ANGELES
HAS BUILT MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
A HUGE INCREASE FROM THEIR
ANNUAL AVERAGE OF ABOUT SEVENTY
EIGHTY USE PER YEAR ONE OF THE
KEY ATTRIBUTES THAT HAS ALLOWED
THAT IS THAT.
LOS ANGELES -- LIKE MANY BEST
PRACTICE CITIES ON THE WEST
COAST DOES NOT REQUIRE.
AN OWNER OCCUPANCY -- AS A
PROVISION OF RECEIVING A PERMIT --
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THAT TO
OTHER CITIES IN THE STATE
POTENTIALLY CATALYZING VERY
LIKELY CATALYZING.
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A TO USE
THEIR IT AB AT ONE WILL LIKELY
RESULT.
IN THOUSANDS OF NEW LOW COST AND
LOW RENT HOMES ALL AROUND
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY URGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER SPOKE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
KEITH THEN CALIFORNIA PARMA SO
STATION HERE IN SUPPORT AUSTAL
PROJECT INNOVATIVE EFFORTS OF
THE THE MEMBER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AUDREY RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE OF ANY OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
WELL SEEING NONE.
WE NEED TO MEET MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS REAVIS
A AND YEAH THAT'S CRAZY A SECOND
BY MYSTERY WITH SIMPLE MEMORY
WAS.
HER WAY.
OKAY -- SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY YOUR YOU SUPPORT THIS
WITH MEN MEN SO I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY TO EVERYONE IN HERE.
I'M DO THE TIME TIMING THE
MINUTES WILL BE CROSSED IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE OKAY.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
BLOOM FOR ACCEPTING OUR
AMENDMENTS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT HAPPENS THAT FIVE
YEAR WINDOW AT THAT POINT
LEGISLATIVE LIP LEGISLATURE CAN
EXERCISE UP.
IT'S OVERSIGHT ON THE OWNER
OCCUPANCY IS OCCUPANCY ISSUE
IT'S A GREAT BILL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
THIS IS A CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
HI BLOOM AYE BURNER OR YEAH
[inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
THREE OF US THREE OF US I ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS FIVE OQO LIKE
VOEPEL HI. TO MAKE.
MEASURES OUT SIX ZERO WILL MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM A WELCOME AGAIN
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE WILL
EXTEND THE PROPERTY TAX WELL FOR
EXEMPTION. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS TO INCLUDE
BELARUS SPECIAL TAXES.
THE MELROSE COMMUNITY FACILITIES
ACT WAS PASSED WAY BACK IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY TWO IS A
RESPONSE TO PROPOSITION.
THIRTEEN AND IT ALLOWS COUNTY
CITIES SPECIAL DISTRICTS OR
JOINT POWER TO ESTABLISH A
COMMUNITY FACILITIES DISTRICT
WITH THE APPROVAL OF THE VOTERS.
RESIDENTS RESIDING IN A
COMMUNITY FACILITIES DISTRICT
ARE ASSESSED A SPECIAL TAX.
ON TOP OF THEIR PROPERTY TAX TO
HELP FUND LOCAL SERVICES
INCLUDING SCHOOLS AND CITY
MAINTENANCE SERVICES.
CURRENTLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS ARE EXEMPT FROM PAYING
PROPERTY TAXES UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
THE PROPERTY TAX WELL FOR
EXEMPTION HELPS REDUCE THE
ANNUAL OPERATING COSTS OF LOW
INCOME HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND
IS CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THE
FINANCIAL FEASIBILITY.
OF LOW INCOME HOUSING.
BUT THE EXEMPTION DOES NOT
INCLUDE THE BELARUS SPECIAL TAX
WHICH CAN BE AS MUCH AS A
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER UNIT PER
YEAR.
CALIFORNIANS NEED ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION MORE AFFORDABLE RENTAL
HOMES TO MEET THE NEEDS OF LOW
INCOME.
HOUSEHOLDS AND RENTERS NEED TO
EARN THREE AND A HALF TIMES THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE TO AFFORD THE
AVERAGE MONTHLY RENT.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE IS AWARE
OF HIS ONGOING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THIS PAST MANY
CRUCIAL POLICIES TO HELP FINANCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND REMOVE
BARRIERS AND CONSTRAINTS TO
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS IS.
ONE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE
WILL HELP CONTINUE THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS. TO SPEAK
MORE ON THE NEED FOR THIS BILL.
WE HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE WITH US
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MARINO WHY IT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
PLEASED TO BE A SPONSOR OF THE
SPELL AND WHEN I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE -- AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT
MENTION AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS
EXAM FROM PAYING PROPERTY TAXES
IN ORDER TO REDUCE THE ANNUAL
OPERATING COSTS OF LOW INCOME
HOUSING WHICH IS CRUCIAL TO
MAINTAIN THE FINANCIAL
FEASIBILITY OF THESE PROJECTS
THIS EXEMPTION -- MOST RECENTLY --
WAS THE INTENT OF THE EXEMPTION
MOST RECENTLY WAS EXTENDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AS IT RELATES TO
PAYMENTS AND LIVE TAXATION.
SIMILARLY YEAH ALTHOUGH NOT
FREQUENT -- VIEWS CFT FEE IS --
CAN HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THE CASH FLOW OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS IN A OR
DRIVE UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMITTEE DO YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
ONCE AGAIN SING NONE --
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND THE SECOND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REVERSE AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REVERSE -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THINGS ARE LOOKING GOOD FOR MY
BILLS TODAY SO I THINK I'LL JUST
KEEP MY MOUTH SHUT RESPECTFULLY
AFTER I'VE.
ALWAYS A GOOD IDEA.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM FOR
BRINGING THIS ONE UP FOR THE
SENATE SENSIBLE STEP TO HELP
INSURE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS WERE BUILDING -- TO STAY
THAT WAY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND SECRETARY TAKE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE BLOOM AYE BLOOM AYE BOERNER
HORVATH.
RAMOS ABILITY THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL LIKE
VOEPEL AYE.
BOERNER HORVATH.
IT'S NOT THE EIGHTY YOU BUILT
[inaudible]
WELL.
SINCE THE COMING TOGETHER.
AYE TURNER HER VAST BY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ALSO.
SEVEN ZERO NEXT WILL BE -- I
HAVE HERE.
I REMEMBER THIRTEEN COM ORDERED
OF AB.
ELEVEN HUNDRED WELCOME WELCOME
HOW ARE YOU. FIFTEEN STILL
STANDING.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
I AM HERE ON THIS WEDNESDAY
PRESENTING AB ELEVEN HUNDRED
WHICH WILL ALIGN THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING CODE.
WITH LOCAL PARKING ORDINANCES TO
SUPPORT ELECTRIC VEHICLE.
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
WHEN AN EEVEE CHARGING STATION
IS INSTALLED AT A PARKING SPACE
THE BUILDING CODE DEFINES
EXPLICITLY?
IT IS A CHARGING SPOT AND NO
LONGER A PARKING SPOT.
THE BUILDING CODE ALSO REQUIRES
THAT ONE OF THE FIRST FOUR
CHARGERS INSTALLED IN A LOT TO
BE INSTALLED IN A VAN ACCESSIBLE
SIZE SPACE.
WHICH PHYSICALLY REQUIRES
COMBINING TO NORMAL SIZE SPOTS.
THESE REQUIREMENTS RESULT IN
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REQUIRING
EVEY CHARGING COMPANIES TO
CONSTRUCT ADDITIONAL PARKING
SPACES TO OFFSET THE LOST
PARKING SPACE. TO MEET LOCAL
PARKING REQUIREMENTS.
BUILDING AN ADDITIONAL PARKING
SPACES OFTEN COSTLY OR
TECHNICALLY FEASIBLE CAUSING
CHARGING PROJECTS TO BE DROPPED
ENTIRELY.
SUCH TECHNICAL ISSUES CREATE
ARBITRARY BARRIERS TO STATION
DEPLOYMENT WHICH IS INCONSISTENT
WITH OUR LONG TERM CLIMATE GOALS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SOMEONE IS A POWER THESE
INCLUDING SO NO MIND SACRAMENTO
COUNTIES AND THE CITIES OF
STOCKTON AND LOS ANGELES TO NAME
A FEW.
HAVE RECOGNIZE THESE ISSUES AND
HAVE PASSED ORDINANCES TO FIX
SOME OF THEM.
HOWEVER MOST OTHER
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE NOT TAKEN
SUCH MEASURES.
WE NEED TO HELP COMMUNITIES
ACCESS THIS IMPORTANT TECHNOLOGY
TO INCREASE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
IN E. VIS.
A. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED HELPS
ACHIEVE THIS BY CLARIFYING THAT
PARKING STALLS WITH EVEY
CHARGING STATIONS CAN STILL
COUNT TOWARDS PARKING
REQUIREMENTS AND WOULD ALSO
ALLOW VAN ACCESSIBLE EVEY SPACES
TO COUNT AS TWO SPARKING PARKING
SPACES. FOR PURPOSES OF
COMPLYING WITH PARKING
REQUIREMENTS.
TODAY WITH ME AND SUPPORT IS
COREY BOLAS WITH THE ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING ASSOCIATION
WELCOME CURRENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CORBELS WITH
THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
ASSOCIATION -- WE ARE COMPRISED
OF LEADING COMPANIES THAT DESIGN
MANUFACTURE INSTALL AND OPERATE --
EVEY CHARGING EQUIPMENT AND
SERVICES MOST OF OUR COMPANIES
ARE HEADQUARTERED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA -- SO THE STATE HAS
VERY AMBITIOUS EVEY DEPLOYMENT
GOALS OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
BY -- TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FIVE
MILLION BY TWENTY THIRTY BUT
ALSO AN AMBITIOUS EVEY CHARGING
DEPLOYMENT GOAL OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND PUBLIC CHARGERS
BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY EMBRACE THOSE
GOALS -- BUT IT IS ALSO GOING TO
MEAN THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
INCREASINGLY FOCUS ON REDUCING
BARRIERS TO DEPLOYMENT.
AND THE ISSUES LAID OUT BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARE REALLY HUGE
ONES FOR US IN TERMS OF
INSTALLING PROJECTS.
AND WE LOSE SCORES OF PROJECTS
EVERY YEAR TO THESE TECHNICAL
ISSUES THAT SHE'S TOUCHED ON AND
JUST BECAUSE OF THE ADDED COSTS
BY BUILDING ANOTHER PARKING
SPACE OR IT'S BECAUSE IT'S
OFTENTIMES TECHNICALLY IN
FEASIBLE WE WE WE JUST CAN'T DO
IT BASED ON HOW THE SPACE IS
BUILT OUT -- AND IN THE CASE OF
DEFINING A PARKING STALL AS A
CHARGING STALL AND THE CAR IS
STILL PARKED WALL YOU'RE
CHARGING SO THE PARKING SPOT AS
WE KNOW IT ISN'T LOST IT IS
STILL THERE -- IN THIS IS NOT A
UNIQUE ISSUE IN ANY ONE CITY OR
COUNTY IT'S WHERE EXPERIENCE IT
EXPERIENCING IT ACROSS THE STATE --
IN MANY PLACES AND WHILE I'M A
LOT OF JURISDICTIONS HAVE TAKEN
ACTION TO FIX THOSE TECHNICAL
ISSUES THOSE ARE IN THE MINORITY --
AS THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS POINTED
OUT -- SO THE END RESULT IS WE
MISS OUT ON TONS OF PRIME
LOCATIONS TO INSTALL CHARGERS
AND THAT'S JUST.
NOT HELPFUL AS IT RELATES TO OUR
DEPLOYMENT GOALS SO -- THIS BILL
WILL FIX THOSE ISSUES AND HELP
TAKE THIS A STEP FORWARD IN THAT
DIRECTION SO WE RESPECTFULLY OR
DRIVE OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS TO LEAVE
ALLEN ASK ABOUT HALF THE
CALIFORNIA LECTER TRANSPORTATION
COALITION ON I'LL LEAVE YOU WITH
ONE THING THIS BILL IS NOT
CREATING A NEW PROGRAM THIS BILL
IS THAT ASKING FOR MORE MONEY
WE'RE JUST ASKING FROM THE VERY
FIXABLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEIA BURNLEY ON
BEHALF OF TEST LE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MICHAEL DAFT ON BEHALF OF CHARGE
POINT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AARON RODRIGUEZ FOR THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
JOINT A LABEL ON BEHALF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I JUST LIKE TO THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR COMING FOR
WITH THIS EXCELLENT BELL THIS IS
BEEN A CHALLENGE IN MY CITY AND
IN MY DISTRICT.
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE THE
LEAD ON THIS AND HELPING ALL
CALIFORNIANS ADOPT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND HELP FIGHT TRIED
CLIMATE CHANGE I'LL BE IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SEEING NONE.
THE MERE MOTION.
PROBLEMS.
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AND WHICH I TO CLOSE.
I'M GOING TO TAKE I'M GOING TO
FOLLOW THE LEAD OF MISTER BLOOM
AND STOP RIGHT HERE WELL I THINK
I MIGHT BE DOING WELL AND JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT I THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
US TO RUN NARROW YOUR BILL TO
ADDRESS MY CONCERNS WITH THE NEW.
AUTHORITY PROVIDES -- YOUR WITH
YOUR ACCEPTANCE OF THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS YES.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT [inaudible]
ONE I'M SORRY.
NEVER MIND OKAY GIVE NO
MINIATURE GOOD.
THANK YOU AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING.
THIS IS TOO MANY HOURS SITTING
BEHIND I'M SORRY ONLY AREA.
SECRETARY CHECK THE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY HIGH
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH BRENT
BURNER HER BATH BY RAMOS.
ROOM RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MEASURE.
MEASURES OUT SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB THREE ZERO FIVE
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE SYRIAN
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO FOR START BY --
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES HAS
EMBARKED ON A SUSTAINABILITY
PROGRAM TO INCREASE ITS LOCAL
WATER SUPPLY REDUCE ITS RELIANCE
ON IMPORTED WATER AND ADDRESS
THE SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES OF
GROUNDWATER CONTAMINATION. FOR
UP TO FIVE YEARS AGO I AUTHORED
AB EIGHT FIFTY WHICH AMENDED THE
JOINT AUTHORS.
A JOINT POWERS ACT TO ALLOW
MUNICIPAL WATER UTILITIES TO
FORM GPAS THAT COULD ISSUE RATE
REDUCTION BONDS TO FUND
NECESSARY WATER CAPITAL PROJECTS.
CRITICAL FOR GROUNDWATER CLEANUP.
THIS BILL IS SET TO SUNSET ON
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY SINCE AB
EIGHT FIFTY WAS ENACTED THE CITY
OF LOS AT THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES HAS BEEN EXAMINING.
PROJECTS TO INCREASE THE RE USE
OF WASTE WATER AND ELLIE DWP
CONTINUES TO WORK. TO SATISFY
RATING AGENCY REQUIREMENTS AND
MODIFY THEIR SYSTEM TO ALLOW THE
LINE ITEM CHARGE TO BE ADDED TO
CUSTOMERS BILLS.
THESE EFFORTS HAVE DELAYED THE
GPA SALE OF RATE REDUCTION BONDS
BUT HAVE BEEN NECESSARY TO MEET
LEGAL OBLIGATIONS AND MAXIMIZE
THE FINANCIAL BENEFIT TO
RATEPAYERS.
AN INDEPENDENT BOND STUDY
PERFORMED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN BY NEVER AGAIN FOR
ELLIE T. W. P..
CONFIRMED THAT SECURED AT THE
SIX SECURITIZED FINANCING USING
REDUCED RATE BONDS PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS COMPARED TO
FINANCING THE SAME.
THE SAME COSTS USING THE WATER
SYSTEM REVENUE BONDS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY USED TO FINANCE LA
D. W. PEAS.
A CAPITAL PROJECTS THE ESTIMATED
GROSS LIFETIME SAVINGS FOR THE
THIRTY YEAR BONDS ARE ESTIMATED
TO RANGE FROM.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
MILLION TO THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DEPENDING ON
INTEREST RATE ASSUMPTIONS.
THE SAVINGS DECREASE THE RETAIL
REVENUE LADWP MUST COLLECT FROM
CUSTOMERS.
ABOUT -- A ONE POINT 3% AVERAGE
ANNUAL REDUCTION OVER THE THIRTY
YEAR LIFE TIME OF THE BONDS.
BASED ON CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES.
OF AB THREE OH FIVE WILL EXTEND
THE SUNSET TELL ALLOW ELLIE W.
P. AND SIMILARLY SITUATED PUBLIC
WATER UTILITIES TO CONTINUE TO
WORK.
TOWARD THE TO DO THE WORK THAT
THEY STARTED AS A RESULT OF AB --
EIGHT FIFTY THIS BILL ALSO
EXTENDS THE ABILITY OF JP'S TO
ISSUE RATE REDUCTION BONDS FOR
QUALIFIED PROJECTS FOR WASTE
WATER SYSTEMS.
AND REFINANCE PUBLIC WATER
UTILITY DEBT ISSUED FOR
QUALIFIED PROJECTS ALLOWING
WATER UTILITIES TO FORM GP'S
WILL RESULT IN INTEREST SAVINGS
LOWERED THAT.
SERVICE AND LOWER LOCAL
BORROWING COSTS WHICH WILL HELP
TO REDUCE FUTURE UTILITY RATE
INCREASES AND WILL ACCELERATE
THE CONSTRUCTION REPAIR AND
MAINTENANCE OF PUBLIC CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS.
I'M JOINED BY AT MANNING ON
BEHALF OF THE LA T. W. P. --
HE'S ACCOMPANIED BY BOND COUNSEL
JOHN PIROGUE WHO IS AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
WELCOME WELCOME GENTLEMEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
NAZARIAN AT MANNING WITH KP ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER.
I'LL LE KEEP IT SHORT THE THE
ANALYSIS WAS A BLANK V. AND AND
OF THE VERY PRECIADO IT.
ON WELL THESE ARE COMPLICATED
FINANCIAL INSTRUMENTS -- THE
BEST WAY TO UNDERSTAND IS WE
HAVE TWO EXAMPLES OF PENDING --
OPPORTUNITIES TO UC'S RATE
REDUCTION BONDS. ONE IS -- AN
EXAMPLE -- AND MISTER HIS
ERRANDS DISTRICT WHICH IS SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY GROUNDWATER
CLEANUP.
WHICH IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
PREPARING TO UC'S RATE REDUCTION
BONDS FOR WHERE.
THE CITIES OF LA GLENDALE
BURBANK AT SIMILAR CONCERNS
ABOUT TRYING TO TREAT
CONTAMINATED GROUNDWATER RE USE
IT.
RECENTLY THERE WAS ALSO AN
ANNOUNCEMENT BY -- MAYOR
CARCETTI ABOUT AMBITIOUS --
PLANS TO TRY TO REDUCE WASTE
WATER DISCHARGE FROM THE
HYPERION PLAN -- AND SO FOR YOU
KNOW REDUCING WASTE WATER AND
SANITATION DISCHARGES AND BE
ABLE TO RE USE THAT WATER TO
PRIME EXAMPLES.
OF THE TYPES OF PROJECTS WHICH
COULD ISSUE THESE RATE REDUCTION
BONDS AND SAVE THE REPAIRS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF MONEY OVER
TIME.
SO -- FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE
ASK YOU FOR NOT VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND TEMPERATURE WITH
US IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO USE SPEAKING OF HAVE TO
OKAY WAS THE VIEW FOR
QUESTIONING.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I NEED A MOTION.
THE MOVE THE BILL.
THE THE SECOND.
YES I DO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HER LIVING IN
THIS TRAFFIC AND HIM.
SORRY NO.
OKAY -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I I THINK I SPOKE QUITE A BIT SO --
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THIS
TYPE OF THESE TYPES OF BONDS
REPRESENTS OPPORTUNITY FOR LA W.
P. AND SIMILAR AGENCIES TO SAVE
SOME MONEY.
SAVING IS ACUTE CARE WERE HERE
ON NEED A PROJECT PLEASE SUPPORT
YOUR BILL THIS AFTERNOON.
AND YOU WILL BE TAKING THIS WITH
THE AMENDMENTS.
AT THE NEXT -- COMMITTEE.
I THINK THAT OKAY.
ALRIGHT WITH THAT -- SECRETARY
TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS DO BASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY HIGH
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BRING HER BACK.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US FIVE
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU RE TRIP UP
HERE -- NEXT WE WILL HAVE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY
WELCOME.
WITH THE STATE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL PROPOSES TO
CHANGES TO THE PROPERTY ASSESSED
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM WHICH IS
ALSO KNOWN AS PACE
IT REQUIRES PACE ADMINISTRATORS
TO PROVIDE PROPERTY OWNERS WITH
A ONE PAGE DISCLOSURE FORM.
PRIOR TO ENTERING INTO A
CONTRACT THE FORMAL CONTAIN
BASIC AND IMPORTANT FINANCIAL
INFORMATION.
SECONDLY THIS BILL PROVIDED
PROHIBITS PACE ADMINISTRATORS
FROM CHARGING PROPERTY OWNERS A
PREPAYMENT PENALTY.
THE LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED PACE
PROGRAM BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WE'VE MADE A NUMBER OF
IMPROVEMENTS IN FINE TUNINGS TO
PACE OVER THE YEARS.
THIS BILL BUILDS UPON PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS BY PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS TO
PROPERTY OWNERS CONSIDERING A
PACE AGREEMENT.
WITH ME TODAY IS ANNA BUCK
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS.
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ANNA BACK ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AB FIFTEEN FIFTY ONE
DOES TWO THINGS ELIMINATES THE
ABILITY OF A PACE ADMINISTRATOR
COMPANY -- TO CHARGE A
PREPAYMENT PENALTY AND IT ADDS
AN ADDITIONAL HARD COPY CONSUMER
FRIENDLY DISCLOSURE THAT MUST BE
SIGNED BY A CONSUMER PRIOR TO
AGREEING TO FINANCING -- AS YOU
ALREADY KNOW PACE IS A UNIQUE
FORM OF FINANCING SANCTIONED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT ALLOWS
PROPERTY OWNERS TO FINANCE WATER
AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AND NOW HOME HARDENING EFFORTS --
WITH A FEW NOTABLE EXCEPTIONS
FINANCINGS MINISTERED -- BY FOR
PROFIT PRIVATE ENTERPRISE OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS DUE TO
NUMEROUS CONCERNS WITH THE
INDUSTRY'S MARKETING AND
DISCLOSURE PRACTICES.
PAGE WAS BROUGHT TO THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION CA ARE
HAS CO SPONSORED OR SUPPORTED.
NUMEROUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION
THAT WILL HAVE THE EFFECT OF
BRINGING THE INDUSTRY UNDER
REGULATORY CONTROL OF THE TV --
AND HAS BROUGHT MANY CONSUMER
PROTECTION PROTECTIONS TO THE
INDUSTRY INCLUDING AN ABILITY TO
PAY ANALYSIS WHICH DID NOT
PREVIOUSLY EXIST.
HOWEVER AN INHERENT CONFLICT OF
INTEREST STILL EXISTS WITHIN THE
PACE PROGRAM STRUCTURE BECAUSE
PASTE ADMINISTRATOR COMPANIES
RELY ON CONTRACTORS WHO WILL BE
INSTALLING THE PRODUCTS. TO SIGN
CUSTOMERS UP FOR THE FINANCING.
THE FINANCING IS REPAID THROUGH
A LINE ITEM ON THE PROPERTY TAX
BILL INCREASE SUPER PRIORITY
LEAVE ON THE IMPROVE PROPERTY.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
PRODUCTS RESULT IN A SECURED
DEBT AND THAT'S HAVE VERY LITTLE
RISK TO THE LENDER THE INTEREST
RATES ARE HIGH AT SIX AND A HALF
TO EIGHT AND A HALF PERCENT.
ADDITIONALLY SOME ADMINISTRATOR
COMPANIES CHARGE FEES AND
PREPAYMENT PENALTIES WHEN A
HOMEOWNER DECIDES TO PAY OFF
THEIR PACE LEAN.
BECAUSE FANNIE MAE AND FREDDIE
MAC WILL NOT PURCHASE A MORTGAGE
THAT HAS A HIGHER LEAN PRIORITY
THEN THERE'S PAYS ASSESSMENTS
MUST BE PAID OFF PRIOR TO THE
SALE OR REFINANCE OF THE
PROPERTY.
AND ADDITIONAL PREPAYMENT
PENALTY ONLY SERVE TO A ROAD
HARDER INEQUITY IN THE PROPERTY
AND WE BELIEVE IT'S POOR PUBLIC
POLICY TO ADD EXTRA FEES AND
PENALTIES TO A GOVERNMENT
ENDORSED FINANCING PROGRAM.
MEANT TO SERVE THE PURPOSE OF
PROMOTING ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
THE BILL ALSO CREATES A CONSUMER
FRIENDLY EASY TO READ DISCLOSURE
THAT STATES IN AND RESTATES
ESSENTIAL TERMS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATIONS.
ALL CAPS IS USE THAT TIME IN THE
DISCLOSURE THING A VERY
IMPORTANT TERMS.
BECAUSE HOMEOWNERS HAVE A RIGHT
TO BE FULLY INFORMED OF ALL THE
RELEVANT FACTS OF THIS FINANCING
ESPECIALLY SINCE THEIR INCOME
BRING.
THEIR VERY MOST IMPORTANT ASSET
THEIR HOME -- WE HAVE REACHED
OUT TO THE INDUSTRY GROUPS AND
ARE WILLING TO WORK WITH THEM ON
THE TERMINOLOGY IN THE
DISCLOSURE HOWEVER WE DO SEE
THIS DISCLOSURE AS AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF THE BILL -- FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
CNN ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRIS ROGERS
UP WITH WHITE GREEN ENERGY FUND
WHY GREEN IS THE LARGEST PACE
PROVIDER IN THE NATION -- BASED
OUT OF BEAUTIFUL CINEMA COUNTY.
WE AS YOU HEARD -- HAVE A BILL
IN FRONT OF US THAT HAS
FUNDAMENTALLY TO DIFFERENT PARTS
THE FIRST PART IS THE PREPAYMENT
PENALTY IN THE DISCLOSURE IN OUR
CONFIRM TERMS PHONE CALL.
OF THAT PREPAYMENT PENALTY OUT
WIDE GREEN ENERGY FUND HAS
MATURED AND HAS ACTUALLY
ELIMINATED OUR PREPAYMENT
PENALTY AND THAT'S BECOME THE
INDUSTRY STANDARD WE HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT PORTION OF THE
BILL.
THE SECOND ASPECT OF THE BILL IS
THE DID THE DISCLOSURE FORM THAT
IS PROVIDED TO THE HOMEOWNER IN
THE BEGINNING -- AS YOU WILL SEE
FROM THE THE CHART THAT I PASSED
OUT YOUR STAFF ALSO HAVE
RECEIVED THIS CHART WE'RE HAPPY
TO MAKE IT AVAILABLE.
NOT ONLY IS THE DISCLOSURE FORM
REDUNDANT WITH THE EXISTING
DISCLOSURE FORM IT WOULD BE
REDUNDANT WITH THE PROPOSED
SECONDARY DISCLOSURE FORM THAT
IS BEING PROPOSED BY THE CSL
BEYOND SOLAR PROJECTS.
IT IS ADDITIONALLY REDUNDANT
WITH OUR CONFIRM TERMS PHONE
CALL -- IF YOU WILL PERMIT ME
FOR A MOMENT IF YOU WERE TO USE
A PACE ASSESSMENT TODAY NOT ONLY
DO YOU NOW HAVE THANKS TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE GREAT WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
pREGULATING THE ADVERTISING THE
CONTRACTOR TRAINING DISPUTES AND
AS WELL AS THE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
BUT IF YOU WERE TO HAVE A
HOMEOWNER I HAVE A CONTRACTOR
PROPOSE -- CHANGES HERE HOME FOR
ENERGY PURPOSES.
THEY WOULD THEN HAND OFF NOT
FROM THE CONTRACTOR BUT TO A
PACE ADMINISTRATOR WHERE IT'S
SIX BAILABLE A TO A PACE
COMPANIES TO TALK WITH SOMEBODY
ABOUT THE FINANCING.
YOU WOULD GET A DISCLOSURE FORM
THAT CONTAINS EVERY SINGLE
ASPECT OF THIS SECONDARY
DISCLOSURE FORM AS YOU CAN SEE
IN STATUTE ALREADY -- YOU WOULD --
AT THAT POINT BE ABLE TO GET A
COPY OF THE CONTRACT THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED.
YOU WOULD THEN HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO NOT SIGN IT
THERE TAKE IT ACT TALK WITH
OTHER FOLKS ABOUT IT COME BACK.
WHEN YOU DECIDED THAT IT WAS
RIGHT FOR YOU TO UTILIZE PACE
FINANCING TO MAKE CHANGES TO
YOUR HOME YOU COULD SIGNED THAT
CONTRACT?
AS SOON AS YOU SIGNED THAT
CONTRACT TO COME SO PACE
ADMINISTRATOR WHO VERIFIES NOT
ONLY THAT THE IMPROVEMENTS ARE
WITHIN THE SCOPE OF OF THE PACE
INDUSTRY.
THAT IT IS NOT OVER PRICING FOR
WHAT WE TYPICALLY SEE FOR THOSE
EIGHT MAKE SURE THAT YOU SPEAK
THE ACTUAL LANGUAGE -- THAT THE
CONTRACT IS IN -- SO THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THE TERMS IT MAKE
SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE ABILITY
TO PAY IT ACTUALLY LOOKS AT THAT
THE PAGE PROVIDER LOOKS AT YOUR
DEBTS VERSES IN YOUR OBLIGATIONS
VERSUS YOUR INCOME.
IT LOOKS AT WHETHER YOU HAVE
ANOTHER PACE ASSESSMENT THAT
LOOKS AT THE HISTORY OF YOUR
PROPERTY.
I IT.
GOES THROUGH AND IT MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE --
DELINQUENT -- TAXES IT MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE PROPER
UNDERWRITING CRITERIA.
ONCE ALL OF THAT IS DETERMINED
WE DO A CONFIRM TERMS PHONE CALL.
WHERE WE STILL CALL YOU BACK WE
WALKED BACK THROUGH WITH YOU
THOSE SAME DISCLOSURES MAKING
SURE YOU KNOW YOUR OBLIGATION
MONTHLY?
MAKE SURE YOU KNOW THAT YOU
STAFF AN IMPOUND ACCOUNT.
IT MAKE SURE AGAIN THAT YOU
SPEAK THE LANGUAGE THAT THE
CONTRACT IS IN -- SO THAT WE
KNOW FOR SURE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ASK AT THE
END OF THE PHONE CALL DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THE OBLIGATION THAT
YOU'RE TAKING ON BECAUSE WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT CONSUMERS
ARE PROTECTED.
IF YOU SAY YES YOU THEN HAVE
THREE MORE DAYS OF THREE DAY
RIGHT TO CANCEL FOR YOU CAN
CANCEL WITH NO PENALTY.
THAT'S NOT WHERE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND IN THE PACE
INDUSTRY IF THE CONTRACTOR THEN
WOULD DO THE WORK ON THE HOME.
IF THERE IS AN ISSUE IF THERE IS
A WORKMANSHIP ISSU OR IF THE
WORK IS NOT ACTUALLY BEEN DONE
WE DON'T PAY THE CONTRACTOR
UNTIL YOU IS THE HOMEOWNER SIGN
OFF. TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WORK
IS DONE ADEQUATELY -- THERE ARE
OTHER EXISTING -- PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE IN LAW SUCH AS TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTRACTORS
THERE'S A WHOLE PROCESS TO KICK
OUT NEGATIVE -- CONTRACTORS FROM
THE PROGRAM NOT JUST FROM ONE
PROVIDER BUT ACROSS THE INDUSTRY
THE D. B. L. HAS OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT SO JUST THE CSL BE --
AND I APOLOGIZE THIS IS GOING ON
SO LONG IT TAKES EVEN LONGER TO
DO ALL THESE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAN TO LIST THEM --
IT SO I WILL POTS THEY'RE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AS I
SAID WHY GREEN AS OPPOSED TO
LESS AMENDED.
IF THE REDUNDANT FORM WAS
REMOVED FROM THE PROCESS WE
DON'T BELIEVE THAT ADDS ANY
VALUE IT DOESN'T ADD FOR
CONSUMERS UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
PREPAYMENT.
PAYMENT -- BàN WITHIN THE BILL --
BUT AS IT EXISTS WE ASK FOR A NO
VOTE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OF WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE YES.
I HAVE A QUESTION -- IF THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR IS
REQUIRED TO ALSO HAVE.
OR PROVIDE THESE DISCLOSURES --
IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES SUCH AS
SPANISH.
IF THAT'S PART OF YOU THAT THAT
YES IT IS -- IT IS THE IN RECALL
IT'S IN ACCORDANCE WITH FEDERAL
AND STATE LAW.
OKAY THANK YOU AND AND AGAIN IF --
THE CONTRACT WAS IN ENGLISH AND
THAT ARE CONFIRMED TERMS PHONE
CALL.
REACHES THE HOMEOWNER IN THEIR
SPEAKING SPANISH AS THEIR
PRIMARY LANGUAGE WE WOULD FLAG
THAT MAKE SURE THAT THEY GOT AN
ACTUAL COPY IN SPANISH OF THE
CONTRACT AND WALKING THROUGH IT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
READY -- I NEED AN ENTERTAINING
MOTION REMOTE SHOULD GET.
SO THE FACT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
I'M WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION AND I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WITH PLEASURE THAT WHY
GREEN.
HAS AGREED TO ACCEPT PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL RELATING TO
CLARIFYING THAT AN ASSESSMENT
MAY NOT CONTAIN A PREPAYMENT
PENALTY -- IF THE COMMITTEE OF
PASSES THE BILL -- WILL ADDRESS
THAT AT THE NEXT A COMMITTEE
STOP WHICH IS BANKING THANK YOU.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A WORKS FOR US
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FIRST OF ALL -- MISTER ROGERS I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
CONVERSATION REGARDING THIS -- I
WILL SAY IS THAT THERE'S SOME
REALLY GOOD PLAYERS.
AND THERE'S SOME THE DON'T PLAY
AS WELL AS YOU DO.
SO I HATE THE LUMP YOU INTO THAT
GROUP BECAUSE I KNOW THAT YOU
GUYS DO A GOOD JOB SO.
WITH THAT BEING SAID I REALLY
HAVE SUPPORTED A PACE OF THE
TRANSPARENCY FROM DAY ONE AND
YET MANY OF YOU KNOW IN THIS
ROOM THAT I HAVE.
I HAD A COUPLE OF BILLS THAT WE
WORK THROUGH AND ALL OF YOU BUT
AT THE TABLE FOR THOSE.
FOR TIGHTENING ENOUGH BUT AGAIN
A LITTLE BIT MORE -- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOUR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCE AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SIXTY EIGHT
TING.
WELCOME MR TING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE BEING BACK IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT -- REAL OF HERE FOR
YOU TO SIT WITH I'M SORRY WHAT.
YOU LIKE TO SIT WITH THIS.
MOVIE I HAVE GOD IN OUR FREE
TIME SO HAPPY TO ANYTIME.
FIRST LET ME JUST THINK THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK LAST YEAR ON A
BILL THAT WAS VERY SIMILAR LET
ME THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF --
FOR THEIR WORK THIS YEAR -- WE
ARE NOT CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ON CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS A TECHNICAL
ERROR THAT WAS IN THE BILL.
AS YOU ALL KNOW.
WE HAVE A FOR THE HOUSING CRISIS
UP AND DOWN THE STATE WE KNOW
THAT EXCESS REDRAWING UNITS ARE
ONE OF THE BEST AND FASTEST WAYS.
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE CITIES
THAT I DON'T SEE IT THAT WAY
THEY SEE IT AS A NUISANCE
UNFORTUNATELY A CITY CLOSE TO
CLOSE TO MY CITY.
OF SAN FRANCISCO PIEDMONT PASSED
A LOCAL ORDINANCE ONLY ALLOWING
HOMEOWNERS TO BUILD EIGHTY USE
ON LOTS THAT ARE. EIGHT THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET OR GREATER --
BASICALLY ESSENTIALLY.
BANNING THEM -- BUT THANKS TO
MUCH OF THE WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE BY.
MANY OF BUT MANY OF US AND MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES -- BOTH HERE
AS WELL AS IN THE SENATE WE'VE
HAD OTHER JURISDICTIONS REALLY --
SEEN IT UP TAKE ON A TO USE IN
MY CITY ALONE WE WENT FROM --
FORTY APPLICANTS IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO NOW A THOUSAND
APPLICANTS IN THE PIPELINE WHICH
IS GREAT US NUMBER COUNTY SANTA
BARBARA COACHING THE BUILDINGS
OF EIGHTY USING JUNIOR EIGHTY
USED TOGETHER TO QUICKLY REBUILD.
HOMES DEVASTATED BY THE FIRES.
AND JUST VERY VERY QUICKLY THE
BILL -- CUTS THE PERMITTING TIME
IN HALF PROHIBITS LOCAL
ORDINANCES THAT RESTRICT LOT
SIZE.
THEY ALSO ELIMINATE THE PARKING
SPACE REQUIREMENT ARE.
IF THAT BURKE LIMITS APARTMENT
THE PARKING SPACES BE REPLACED
GARAGE IS CONVERTED. TO AN
EIGHTY YOU AND ALSO ALLOWS
MINISTRO APPROVAL FOR EIGHTY
USING J. JUNIOR IDEAS WITH AN
EXISTING SPACE -- AGAIN WE WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS -- EIGHTY YOU
STREAMLINING IS NEEDED AS SORT
OF FOLLOW UP WORK FOR MANY OF
THE EIGHTY USE THAT WERE BUILT --
THAT BILLS THAT WERE DONE IN
YEARS PAST REALLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR EITHER DISCONNECTED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LUIS MAR ON TEH WITH
CALIFORNIA BE I THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DID A VERY FINE
JOB SUMMARIZING AT THAT.
POINT THE BILL -- I WOULD JUST
THAT SAY THAT SB SIXTY A IS IS
BASED ON BEST PRACTICES ALREADY
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY IN LA.
I'M NOT ALLOWING THAT MINIMUM
LOT SIZE IS KEY.
TO GETTING MORE EIGHTY IS BUILT --
I'D STRONGLY URGE AND I THE
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM CHAIR -- KEEPS
ON HER BEHALF CALIFORNIA
PURPOSES STATION AGAIN PLEASE TO
SUPPORT -- ALTERNATE IS DEFINED
FOR WILL HOUSING FOR CITIZENS.
SAYS THE MAN THAT WHITE HOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIANS PORT.
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SPECTRUM OF A
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
DINI'S PINKSTON WITH A CASITA
COALITION A STATEWIDE GROUP OF
EIGHTY YOU BOOSTERS AND PLANNERS
THAT SPAN FROM SAN DIEGO TO THE
NORTH COAST WERE NEW AND WE'RE
REALLY GLAD TO SEE THIS
LEGISLATION COME FORWARD THANKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TIFFANY VAN ON HOW THE BRIDGE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TODD DAVID ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WANT A TWEENER I THINK I
BETWEEN -- THE FIRST ONE FOR THE
DAY ONE UP.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA
VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES.
OF CALIFORNIA NO OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL I WE HAVE
EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS WITH
PROVISIONS RELATED TO THE NUMBER
OF EIGHTY USE IN JUNIOR EIGHTY
USE ON MULTI FAMILY.
LOTS BUT WE BELIEVE THAT WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS NOT ON ONLY ON
THAT ISSUE BUT A NUMBER OF OTHER
AMENDMENTS THE AUTHORS TAKEN ON
BEHALF OF A PAY CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH SO.
JUST WANTED TO THANK HIM FOR ADD
THE AMENDMENTS AND CONTINUE TO
LOOK FORWARD. TO WORKING WITH
HIM TO RESOLVE THE RESTAURANT
CONCERNS THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
YES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WERNER HARPER.
THANK YOU -- I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS UP FORD PROBABLY IN MY
DISTRICT EIGHTY YEARS ARE THE
ONLY TYPE OF ACCEPTABLE.
HOUSING AND CREE SAID AS THE
HOUSING CRISIS -- AND SO -- I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT CITIES
LIKE MINE WHERE THEY PROBABLY
HAVE CHALLENGES AND ALL OTHER
THINGS HAVE ADOPTED VERY VERY
LIBERAL EIGHTY YOU POLICIES.
BUT EVEN THOUGH YOUR BILL WOULD
GO AGAINST THOSE AND SO I THINK
WE HAD A CONVERSATION TODAY HAVE
A FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU I
WILL NOT BE VOTING ON THE STATE
BUT IT TODAY BUT I LOOK FORWARD
TO US CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER
HEALTH LIKE INFO FOR IT.
ON THE FLOOR ABSOLUTELY I THINK
AGAIN -- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
CITIES THAT ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING ARE GETTING PENALIZED OR
NOT -- CREATING MIXED MESSAGES
WE DEFINITELY WANT TO BE MAKING
SURE PERCENT CONSISTENT MESSAGES
ESPECIALLY THE CITIES THAT ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING THEN I NEED A MOTION.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHICH
I TO CLOSE I JUST RESPECT PAST.
FIVE OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR BRINGING THE BILL FOR
MR TING AS SOME REMEMBER TING.
IT'S SIMILAR TO THE ONE THAT YOU
HAD LAST YEAR AND I SUPPORTED
THEY'LL BE DOING IT AGAIN TODAY
THANK YOU.
SECRETARY TAKE THE ROLE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER **** BATH
[inaudible]
RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
BILLS UP FIVE ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO YOUR NEXT
ONE MR TING ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX THANK YOU.
AB FORTY SIX ARE SURPLUS LAND
BILL FIRST FOR ME TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN
THE CHAIR FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
BILL AND HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS -- ALSO
I'M COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING
CONCERNS REGARDING LOCAL ZONING
DESIGNATION SO WILL BE MEETING
WITH VARIOUS INTEREST GROUPS TO
TRY TO FIND A WORKABLE.
SOLUTION THIS IS A FOLLOW UP I
JUST THIS IS A FOLLOW UP TO MY
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
THAT -- GAVE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS THE FIRST RIGHT OF
REFUSAL ON SURPLUS PUBLIC LANDS.
UNFORTUNATELY WHAT WE SAW IS
ONCE THAT LAW WENT INTO EFFECT --
SO JURISDICTIONS TRY TO
CIRCUMVENT IT I JUST TO SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES CALTRAIN -- IN IN THE
BAY AREA DID NOT OFFER A SITE --
BY ITS HE WORE PARK STATION TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
AND STAND WORK EXCLUSIVELY WITH
A MARKET RATE DEVELOPER -- THE
CITY BURLINGAME THE CREDIT
HEALTH DISTRICT ON THE SIDE OF A
PLUMBER PUBLIC HOSPITAL WITH A
PROPOSED TO BUILD A SENIOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTER WITH
NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO AGAIN WE WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE HAVE --
MANY OF OUR GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
HAVE SURPLUS PUBLIC LAND WE JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT HOUSE THEY DISPOSE OF THAT
THAT THEIR PRIORITIES REALLY ARE
LINED WITH OUR PRIORITIES WHICH
HAVE TO BE AROUND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
SO AGAIN WE HAVE TO CLARIFY
POSITION BY PROVISIONS I WOULD
CREATE WE'RE ASKING THE QUESTION
TO STATEWIDE DATABASE AS WELL AS
BUILDING ON THE COVERAGE
EXECUTIVE ORDER FOR STATE
INVOLVEMENT AND ALSO LEVERAGING.
HOUSING ELEMENT LOT MOST USE AND
EFFICIENCY OF THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEROKEE ARE
CURRY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS PATRICK ALTHOUGH AND
I'M WITH THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE FORTY YEAR OLD THE FOR
THE HOUSING ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION -- WITH SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MEMBERS
REPRESENTING BUSINESSES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
PLANNERS AND JUST REGULAR PEOPLE
WHO BELIEVE THAT EVERYONE SHOULD
HAVE AN AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL
HOME -- AND WE THINK THAT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL HELP US
GET THERE ESPECIALLY IN THE BAY
AREA.
NO ONE CAN DENY THAT OUR THAT
OUR STATE IS FACING AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING EMERGENCY.
WE HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
HOMELESS PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY
AND WE RANK BILL HIGHEST IN
TERMS OF POVERTY RATE WHEN
HOUSING COSTS ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT -- BUILDING MORE
AFFORDABLE HOMES FOR SENIORS
VETERANS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES IS A MORAL
IMPERATIVE AND PUBLICLY OWNED
LAND PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
MAKING THAT HAPPEN.
SO.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIANG SIDE CLARIFIES AND
STRENGTHENS THE CAROL CALIFORNIA
SURPLUS LAND ACT THE LAW THAT
HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR FIFTY
YEARS.
BUT THAT HAS SUFFERED FROM
SPOTTING ENFORCEMENTS -- THE
PURPOSE OF THE SURPLUS LAND ACT
IS TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC LAND IS
USED FOR THE PUBLIC GOOD.
WHEN IT IS NO LONGER NEEDED FOR
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES -- BY
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT ARE
DISPOSING OF THAT PLAN TO
PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT AND OPEN SPACE ON
THAT PLAN.
UNDER CURRENT LAW -- WHILE LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
DO THIS LIKE I SAID FOR FIFTY
YEARS THERE HAS BEEN -- SPOTTING
ENFORCEMENT AND THE AND THIS
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX
ADDRESSES MANY OF THE ISSUES
WITH GETTING THE LAW AND FORCED.
SUCH AS FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL
CREATE A STATEWIDE DATABASE OF
PUBLICLY OWNED SITES AND HOW
THEY ARE CURRENTLY BEING USED.
THIS IS TO PROVIDE CLARITY ON
WHAT LAND EVEN EXISTS -- IF YOU
ASK MANY LOCAL AGENCIES THEY DO
NOT FULLY KNOW WHAT THEY OWN --
IT WILL CREATE A PROCESS FOR
STATE PLANS THAT MIRRORS THE
PROCESS FOR LOCAL AGENCIES AND
DISPOSING OF THEIR LANDS TO
PRIORITIZE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BECAUSE CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW.
STATE LANDS AND LOCAL AGENCY ON
LANDS ARE FOLLOW DIFFERENT
TRACKS AND SO IT CREATES AS ST
THE SAME PROCESS PURPLE.
IT CLARIFIES THAT PUBLICLY OWNED
LAND IS NOT SURPLUS IF IT IS
SERVING ANY GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSE --
AND SO THIS THIS PROVIDES
CRITICAL CLARITY THAT IF YOU
BOUGHT THE LAND FOR A PARKER IF
YOU BOUGHT THE LAND FOR SCHOOL
AND YOU'RE USING THE LAND FOR
PARKER SCHOOL.
AND HAD MAKING I'M A MOTION TO
DO SO THAT LAND IS NOT SURPLUS
IT IS BEING USED FOR
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSE.
AND IT ALSO HAS SOME CRITICAL
EXEMPTIONS -- THERE'S OVER
SEVENTEEN OF THEM HOME SO I'M
NOT GOING TO GO THROUGH ALL OF
THEM BUT CRITICAL EXEMPTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSE IF THE LAND
IS BEING USED FOR LEGITIMATE
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES THAT THOSE
ARE EXEMPTED OUT OF THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT.
AND SO THIRTIES ANOTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SIX WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
THOUSANDS OF ACRES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE MOMENT MAINLY BEING
USED AS PARKING LOT OR SITTING
EMPTY CAN BE USED TO HOUSE.
ARE LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WHO
CAN NO LONGER AFFORD TO LIVE
HERE.
AND SO -- BY PASSING THIS BILL
WE ARE GOING TO HELP TO BRING TO
LIFE A PROMISE THAT THE STATE
MADE OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO.
THAT PUBLIC LANDS OUGHT TO
BENEFIT THE PUBLIC GOOD SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME CHAIR IDEACURRY --
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MY NAME IS A FRIEND
GOT EAGLE HERE WITH BURBANK
HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE NONPROFIT --
FORCIBLE HOUSING DEVELOPER -- WE
HAVE LED THE NORTH BAY I
COMMUNITIES -- IN MAINTAINING
QUALITY SUSTAINABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
DEVELOP A LAND IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST OBSTACLES AND
SIGNIFICANT HURDLES.
IN BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OFTEN TIMES IT'S NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS THAT ARE LEFT WITH
THE PARCELS THAT ARE MOST
DIFFICULT TO BUILD.
OFTENTIMES PASSED BY MARKET RATE
DEVELOPERS.
BUY MORE OFFICIALLY TRANSFORMING
HOW PUBLIC LANDS INTO PUBLIC
COULD NOT PROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPERS LIKE US CAN DO MORE --
WE DO BELIEVE THAT BY CLARIFYING
AND STRENGTHENING THE KEY
PROVISIONS OF THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT.
WOULD BE ABLE TO CREATE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOW HOMES IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
THE ISSUE IS ONLY BECOME GREATER --
IN THE NORTH BAY -- THE RECENT
LOSS OF THOUSANDS OF HOMES --
WITH THE WILD FIRES OVER LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS -- AND WITH
FIFTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
CURRENTLY ON A WAIT LIST -- WE
MUST LOOK AT ALL AVAILABLE TOOLS
AND PUBLIC LANDS CAN AND DO PLAY
A VITAL ROLE IN REBUILT AND ARE
REBUILDING EFFORTS.
AS A FORMER SUPERVISOR IN THE
COUNTY OF CINEMA I HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF WORKING ON THE
COUNTIES HOUSING FOR ALL
PRIORITIES.
FOCUSING ON THE RE USE OF SELECT
COUNTY OWNED PROPERTIES FOR
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THAT COULD
BRING UP TO THIRTEEN HUNDRED
UNITS INTO THECOMING YEARS --
THERE IS GREAT ALIGNMENT WITH
WHAT THE COUNTY IN CITIES AND
CINEMA COUNTY ARE DOING -- IN
COLLABORATION WITH CITIES WERE
ALSO ESTIMATING THE DEVELOPING
OF TWO THOUSAND ADDITIONAL UNITS
INVOLVING PUBLICLY OWNED PARCELS
THERE SANTA ROSA JUNIOR COLLEGE
AS WELL AS A SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE HAVING THE SAME CONVERSATION.
I LIKE THAT MY REMARKS WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT THAT OCCURRED TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS AGO THE CITY OF
SANTA ROSA OWNED A VACANT UNUSED
PARCEL.
THAT WAS DâN DONATED TO HABITAT
FOR HUMANITY.
THAT HABITAT WAS ABLE -- TO FOR
BUILD ITS FIRST HOME -- THROUGH
THIS PARTNERSHIP AND EVEN THOUGH
I WAS TEN YEARS OLD WHEN THIS IT
TOOK PLACE -- I KNOW IT SO WELL
BECAUSE IT WAS MY FAMILY THAT
ACTUALLY HAD THE CHANCE TO LIVE
IN THAT HOME -- FOR MY IMMIGRANT
PARENTS WHO ONLY RECEIVED A
GRADE SCHOOL EDUCATION FOR
MEDICAL THIS WAS A PIVOTAL POINT
AND GAME CHANGER AND CERTAINLY
ONE FOR ME.
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOES
CHANGE LIVES -- AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK BEFORE YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES AND A SUPPORT.
CHURCH MEMBERS ALSO WEB TO
ATTEND THE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITIES OF
LIVERMORE DOUBLE IN PLEASANTON
THAT DANVILLE AND SAN RAMON.
I WILL HAVE A FORMAL SUPPORT
POSITION AND YOU YET BUT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE WOULD --
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
MARINO WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TYRONE BUCKLEY
HOUSING CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
PUBLIC FOR MANY LIGHT HAS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF A HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS PART THANK
YOU.
LOUIS MARIN DOWN TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA BID SPORT.
SHANNON DODGE MEMBER OF THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND PH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
IN THE HEART MEN ON BEHALF AGREE
BUT ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
IN THE SPRING SAID ON BEHALF OF
BAY AREA COUNCIL HOUSING
COMMITTEE SUPPORT.
KEEP THE ROW ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS IN SUPPORT
.
AARON RICHIE MEMBER EAST BAY
HOUSING ORGANIZATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI DAVID WITH THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT. TWO THREE PHANTOM ON
HAVE A BRIDGE HOUSING IS PART.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
ROUNDER ROSTER CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY POST MUST
AMENDED TO THE MEASURE.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERN IS THE
APPLICATION OF THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT TO LEASES -- THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC FOR PUBLICATION SEES
THAT DO HAVE VALID REASONS TO
LEASE OR OTHERWISE PROTECT THE
LAND THAT THEY OWN FOR INSTANCE
MANY OF OUR HEALTH CARE
DISTRICTS.
THE STOP THEIR FACILITIES TO
MEDICAL PROVIDERS FOR REDUCED
RATE THIS PROVIDES A PUBLIC
BENEFIT AS WELL AS HELP SUPPORT
THEIR MISSION.
SECONDLY.
OF OUR CEMETERY DISTRICTS LEASE
UP THEIR LAND TO FARMERS PRIOR
PRIOR TO USING THE LAND FOR
FUTURE.
FUTURE BURIALS THIS IS A LOW
IMPACT WAY OF USING THE LAND IT
RESULTS IN NOT HAVING TO TEAR
OUT HOUSING OR AFFECT PEOPLE
ONCE THE LAND COMES BACK TO THE
DISTRICT
AB FOR FUTURE BURIALS.
WE WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND THE
COMEDIAN AUTHOR FOR TODAY'S
AMENDMENTS WHICH REMOVE LEASES
FROM THE SCOPE THE BILL IN THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT.
I WE DO STILL HAVE CERTAIN
OUTSTANDING ISSUES ON THE BILL --
FIRSTLY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
BILL HAVE A PROCESS THAT ALLOWS
AGENCIES.
DISCRETION TO DETERMINE WHAT
LANDIS ACTUALLY SURPLUS TO THE
MISSION AND PURPOSE.
AND SECONDLY AGENCIES DO YOU
HAVE A NEED FOR INFORMAL AND
FORMAL NEGOTIATIONS -- MEETING
WITH DEVELOPERS ME WITH REAL
ESTATE AGENTS THIS HELPS THEM
ASSESS THE MARKET VALUE OF THEIR
LAND AND MAKE GOOD DECISIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC.
SO WITH THAT WOULD JUST LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL SO
FAR.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THIS DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR IN THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I HAS THEIR BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS ARE WE WERE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDMENT AMENDED
TO THE ORIGINAL BILL AND HAVE
NOT YET HAD.
THE TIME TO LOOK OVER THE
AMENDMENTS BUT WE DO THINK THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH US OUR OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN.
IS ALIGNED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
TERMS OF OUR HOSPITAL LEASES --
WE WANT THE ABILITY TO USE OUR
HOSTAGE TO LEASE LAND FOR
HEALTHCARE PURPOSES WHEN IT
MAKES SENSE -- BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE -- AND
READING OVER THE AMENDMENTS AND
OUT WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ARE THERE'S OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
HELLO AGAIN MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE
ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTIES --
BROKE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA.
EVERY COUNTY BUT SUBURBAN
COUNTIES APPARENTLY THIS
AFTERNOON -- WE WERE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
STATED REGARDING THE LEASE
PROVISIONS APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TODAY SO WE ARE GOING
TO REVIEW THAT MET -- BILL AS
AMENDED AND REEVALUATE OUR
POSITION SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU WE WILL ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION SAYING NONE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
YES.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR THIS BILL WE HAD A
TWO YEAR FIGHT IN MY CITY
BETWEEN THE WATER DISTRICT AND
THE CITY COUNCIL IRONICALLY WE
WERE THE SAME PEOPLE ON BOTH --
THAT HAVE THIS AND THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE ABSOLUTE CLARITY
THAT THE WOMEN WERE RIGHT.
SO -- I APPRECIATE WILL ALL BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE'LL WE'LL WE'LL GET THE ANSWER
THAT QUESTION.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THE EMOTION [inaudible]
IN MOTION.
AND THE SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE DISTRICT
THING IS JUST VERY QUICKLY
REALLY THANK -- THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
WELL LEASES THAT THAT'S BEEN
REMOVED.
AGAIN JUST READ REALLY QUICKLY I
THINK IN TERMS OF MARKET VALUE
WE DO BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO DETERMINE MARKET
VALUE -- FOR EXAMPLE A MARKET
APPRAISALS TOLLEY A REASONABLE
WAY TO DO THAT -- IN TERMS OF
DISCRETION THAT THE CHALLENGES
WITH DISCRETION AS WE'VE SEEN
THE PAST AS IF YOU GIVE THE
DISTRICTS THE DISCRETION
UNFORTUNATELY.
THEY'LL BASICALLY SAY NOTHING A
SURPLUS I THINK THAT'S THAT'S
ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES -- SO
AGAIN.
HAPPY TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
WE HOPE THAT WE CAN OBVIOUSLY IF
WE CAN REACH AGREEMENT LEAST
ISSUE.
HOPING THAT WE CAN FIND
AGREEMENT ON SOME OF THE OTHER
ISSUES MOVING FORWARD BUT
RESPECT FAST FIVE I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- HI.
THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS LISTENING
ANALYSIS THIS IS AN AMBITIOUS
BILL I SUPPORT YOUR WORK ON
TIGHTENING UP TO STATUTES
RELATED TO SURPLUS LAND FOR BOTH
THE STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES.
I HAVE ASKED MY COMMITTEE STAFF
TO CONVENE A STAKEHOLDER MEETING
WITH YOUR SPONSORS AND
SUPPORTERS AND THE OPPOSITION
THE CAME HERE TODAY -- WITH THE
CONCERNS TO TALK WITH CONCERNS
ABOUT THE LEASING LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL AND CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE IN HOPES THAT WE MAY
BE ABLE TO FIND.
SOME LEVEL OF MIDDLE GROUND IN
THE COMING MONTHS.
THAT'S MY COMMITMENT TO YOU I
WOULD ASK THAT THE LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT ARE IN THE ROOM
ENGAGE IN THIS PROCESS AS WELL
SUPPORTERS IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
WITHOUT A BE SUPPORTING A BILL
TODAY THANK YOU.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE.
ON HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER **** BATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO [inaudible]
BILLS UP.
BILLS OUT FIVE TO ONE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT NEXT WILL HAVE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB TWO SEVEN FOUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRISON TEEN
AB -- TWO SEVENTY FOUR THIS BILL
SIMPLY BRINGS CLEAN WATER TO THE
CITY OF PORTABLE KNOWN AS THE
CITY WITHOUT WATER.
AND IS A GREAT PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE CITY THE COUNTY AND
THE TO THE RIVER TRIED.
TODAY WITH ME -- PRESENTING IS
GERRY SANTOS FROM THE TO THE
RIVER -- TRIBE DIRECTOR OF TO
THE RIVER LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
AND ALSO MIKE READ FROM THE CITY
OF PORTABLE AND UNFORTUNATELY
OUR SUPERVISOR WAS UNABLE TO
MAKE IT TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME.
THANK YOU TO KEEP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- ON
BEHALF OF THE TOUR TRY BUT THIS
IS JUST ONE OF THE GRAY --
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE GOING WITH
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEN --
WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK YOU
GUYS AND HOPEFULLY WE GET A A
YES VOTE ON YOU GUYS TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- FILL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MICHAEL
READ PUBLIC WORKS DIRECTOR CITY
PORT OF BILL.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THE THE
LACK OF OF QUALITY WATER THE
CITY PORTABLE -- WHICH WAS A
STRUGGLING APPROVING THIS
PROJECT WITH THE TRIBE -- THE
TRIBE IN THE CITY PORTABLE IS
FORMED A STRONG PARTNERSHIP AND
IN PROBLEM SOLVING THIS THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION. TO THE
POINT WHERE -- I THINK WE WE
RESOLVE THE CAPACITY NEEDS FOR
THE PROJECT ALSO LONG POTENTIAL
LONG TERM NEEDS THAT WILL HELP
US IN THE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
AND WITH THAT I CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WAS THERE ANY -- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I LIKE THIS PHONE BILLS.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SELL SOMEONE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
ROOM MOTION SECOND IN A SECOND.
PROJECT CLOSE.
AGAIN COMMITTEE THIS IS JUST --
GREAT PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE
TRIBE THE CITY IN THE COUNTY.
AND WE DON'T GET TO SEE THESE
THINGS EVERY DAY CHAU REALLY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL.
OKAY -- UP ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS
THANK YOU FOR OFFERING THIS BILL.
THESE COMMUTERS ARE STILL
REELING FROM THE RECENT DROUGHT
AND FUNDING IS NECESSARY TO
PROVE THEIR WATER INFRASTRUCTURE
TO THEY'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL.
THANK MANAGER OKAY -- SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY LACKEY AYE
BLOOM BLOOM I REMEMBER BACK
BURNER HER ABOUT THAT I RAMOS
THREE OF US THREE OF US I ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
HELLO I IMAGE.
MEASURES OUT SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS AGAIN THOSE
PEOPLE WATER.
EIGHTEEN AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY MS
COULD DEAL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CLEO WELCOME BACK.
I MISSED YOU.
I MISS YOU.
TOO I BELIEVE MADAM CHAIR THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME THAT I'M
PRESENTING IN YOUR COMMITTEE.
EXCITED THE FIRST DRIVER THING --
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY WHICH WILL
BETTER EQUIP CITIES AND COUNTIES
WITH THE NECESSARY TOOLS TO
PROTECT AND ENCOURAGE THE GROWTH
OF SMALL BUSINESS.
THIS BILL WILL DIRECT OFFICE OF
PLANNING AND RESEARCH IN
COLLABORATING WITH STATE
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO BETTER TO DEVELOP
BEST PRACTICE GUIDELINES. TO
PROVIDE ONGOING COMPREHENSIVE
SUPPORT FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA WAS HOME TO THREE
POINT NINE MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES AND INDUSTRIES SUCH
AS RETAIL TRADE CONSTRUCTION AND
FOOD SERVICES.
SMALL BUSINESS ALSO PROVIDES
CULTURAL AND ECONOMIC CAPITAL IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS AT THE OFFERED
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND NEW JOBS.
JUST LAST YEAR AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN THE ECONOMIC SECURITY
AND LIVELIHOOD OF SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT TO STAND THERE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES CAN BE
SEVERELY IMPACTED DUE TO
WIDESPREAD WIDESPREAD
NEIGHBORHOOD GENTRIFICATION.
AS A RESULT OF GENTRIFICATION
COMMUNITIES OFTEN MUST ADJUST TO
A RISING COST OF LIVING AND
SMALL BUSINESSES MUST ABSORB.
THEIR SURGING COSTS OF RENT IN
ADDITION TO CONTINUE AS
INCREASES IN BUSINESS START UP
AN OPERATING COST.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY WILL DIRECT
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES THAT REPRESENT BEST
PRACTICES TO PROTECT AND
ENCOURAGE.
THE GROWTH OF SMALL BUSINESSES
BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU ARE
THEIR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ARE THE WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
LET'S SEE AND KNOW ALL THE WAY
AROUND -- I'D LIKE TO MENTION
INTO MOTION.
OKAY WERE MOTION AND THE SECOND.
AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SMALL BUSINESSES
CREATE JOBS INNOVATION AND
STRAIGHTEN OUR COMMUNITIES AB
SEVENTEEN TWENTY WILL BETTER
EQUIP LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
SUPPORT THESE VALUABLE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
WITH THEIR COMMUNITIES WE OFTEN
TALK ABOUT TENANT RIGHTS WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING BUT WE OFTEN
NEVER HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SMALL BUSINESSES AND WHAT THEY
FACE WHEN THEY FACE.
INCREASES INCREASES IN RENT
WHICH TO CHANGE THE FACE VALUE
OF A COMMUNITY SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY THANK
YOU.
SECRETARY FOR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I BRING HER THAT.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
THREE OF US THREE OF US I ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I OUT SEVEN ZERO
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU REMOVE
UNDER ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB.
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR COLLEAGUES -- SHOULD
COMMITTEE STAFF WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS I DO SO -- EXCEPT THE
AND THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS --
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE BUILT UPON THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER. TO
CREATE A DIGITIZED INVENTORY OF
SURPLUS STATE PROPERTY.
I THAT COULD BE USED FOR FOR
WHAT HOUSING AND SO THE IDEA
BEHIND THIS BILL IS TO CREATE A
SEARCHABLE INVENTORY OF SURPLUS
LOCAL -- THE LOCAL -- THE
GOVERNOR PROPERTY THAT FOCUSES
ON INFILL AND HIGH DENSITY
PROJECTS -- AND SO IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT THE DECISIONS ON WHAT
TO DO WITH THE SURPLUS PROPERTY
ARE ENTIRELY LET THE LOCAL
CONTROL.
AND SO THE GOAL IS TO HELP
CREATE UNEXPECTED OPPORTUNITIES
FOR SMART PROJECTS. TO HELP MEET
OUR HOUSING NEEDS -- AND
ACCORDING TO THE BILL -- OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES WOULD REPORT --
THE INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
WHICH WOULD CREATE -- A DATABASE --
I AND I HAD BEEN WORKING WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEEING AND I'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM ARE
BILLS ARE A LITTLE DIFFERENT --
AND SO CERTAINLY -- LOOK FOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT -- YOU KNOW.
WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO TWO
OUT WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND THEN --
I DO HAVE A WITNESS HERE WHO --
IS HERE IN SUPPORT SO.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
BUT I'M CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
SPECK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATIONOF
REALTORS WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
BUT WE BELIEVE THAT THE THE
EFFORTS BY THIS ON WOMEN WILL
HELP -- TO STREAMLINED THE
EFFORTS BY THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
IN HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER BY
IDENTIFYING LOCAL SITES
AVAILABLE FOR A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
I'M IT MAY ALSO RESULT AS WE
CREATE AND POPULATE THE TGS
DATABASE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXCHANGE LAND BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE STATE
GOVERNMENT IF ANOTHER SITE IS
NECESSARY.
IT'LL FACILITATE THAT
COMMUNICATION IF WE KNOW WHAT
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
HAPPENING ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
LAURIE JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SALINAS AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
GOOD MOVE.
ARE THERE ANY -- WITNESSES
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES -- COULD YOU MOST CITIES A
HAVE TO ALREADY REPORT THE SITES
OF THEIR IDENTIFYING FOR HIGH
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATES.
SO WHAT IS THE INTENTION OF
DOING ADDITIONAL REPORTING THAT
CAUSES A MINISTRY OF COSTS FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IF THEY'RE
ALREADY BEING IDENTIFIED IN THE
HOUSING ELEMENT UPDATES.
SO THE REASON WE HAVE THIS BILLS
BECAUSE THESE PROBABLY AREN'T BE
IDENTIFIED IN -- CERTAINLY THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ALREADY DO AND SO
THE WHAT SO WHAT THIS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT IS ABOUT UNEXPECTED
OPPORTUNITIES AND SO REALLY
MAKING SURE THAT WE FOLLOW IN
THE GOVERNOR'S -- YOU KNOW
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO IDENTIFY
SURPLUS STATE PROPERTIES -- THIS
WILL TAKE A STEP FURTHER TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ALSO HAVE THESE OPPORTUNITIES --
AND THAT WOULD ADDRESS A
SIGNIFICANT NEED YOU KNOW
ALTERNATELY IT'S ABOUT
ESTABLISHING UNEXPECTED
PARTNERSHIPS -- AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MEET OUR HOUSING GOALS
BASED ON OUR IN OUR ARENA
NUMBERS -- AND SO THIS IS JUST
ANOTHER TOOL IT'S ANOTHER TOLD
TO MAKE SURE THAT -- WE'RE
ATTACKING -- AND YOU KNOW THIS A
HOUSING CRISIS AND DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN FROM YOU KNOW A STATE
STANDPOINT AND WHAT I REALLY
LIKE ABOUT THIS.
IS WE ARE MAINTAINING LOCAL
CONTROL THE ALTERNATELY THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE GOING TO
DO WHEN THEY'RE GONNA MAKE THE
DECISIONS ABOUT THEIR LAND USE
PATTERNS AND AND YOU KNOW WHAT
CAN YOU HAVE IF THAT THEY
IDENTIFY THESE INFILL
OPPORTUNITIES.
IT'S ENTIRELY UP -- TO YOU KNOW
THEIR DISCRETION.
SOMEONE IF I MIGHT.
THIS BILL WORK FANTASTIC -- THE
SOMEONE NUMBER TINGS BILL WHICH
IS GONNA BECAUSE DH CD TO
ACTUALLY DO THE COMPILATION
RIGHT NOW THE INFORMATION AS
REPORTED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
TO DHC DEEP BUT THERE'S NOTHING
DONE WITH IT AFTER THAT AND THE
GOAL AT THIS POINT IS TO CREATE
THAT ONLINE USABLE REPOSITORY --
SO IT'LL BE A PARTNERSHIP IN THE
IN BETWEEN AS WOMEN REVERSES
BILL AND IS A MEMBER KINGS BILL
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INFORMATION IS GIVEN THE TGS.
AND THEN PROVIDED THE PUBLIC IN
A FORMAT THAT'S EASILY
SEARCHABLE.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND I THINK --
COMING FROM AN AREA WHERE
HOUSING IS DIFFICULT AND FINDING
A VERY BUILT OUT AND FINDING
MORE PROPERTIES IS EVEN MORE TO
WELL I THINK THERE'S AN
ADMINISTRATIVE HURDLE.
THAT THE CITIES OF MY DISTRICT
WOULD FACE AT THIS TIME I WILL
NOT BE VOTING ON THE BILL BUT
I'M HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU.
AND SEE IF THERE'S A PLACE WHERE
WE CAN GET TO WHERE WHERE IT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN I
COULD VOTE ON THE FLOOR THANK
YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND IT'S DOING THAT WE HAVE A
MOTION CORRECT.
I NEED A MOTION [inaudible]
THE BILL.
OUR MOTION AND A SECOND.
WELL I WASN'T.
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
OKAY -- SO TODAY OF THE
AMENDMENTS -- JUST TO THE TIMING
YOUR PAYMENTS WILL BE TAKEN IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE WE AGREE WITH
THAT OKAY.
SO THANK YOU FOR ACCEPTING THOSE
MOMENTS I THINK THIS INVENTORIES
NECESSARY TO STEP IN A STEP IN
HELPING TO REACH OUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS.
I'M PLEASED TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL
TODAY THE COMMAND SHIP.
OKAY SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
HI AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I A BURNER HARDBACK.
RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US I ROBERT RIVAS HI ROBERT
RIVAS I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I BILLS US SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB FIVE NINE ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THE CENTRAL
BASIN SINCE I GOT HERE -- MY
AREA HAS BEEN THE OF THE
CORRIDOR CORRUPTION AND THIS IS
ONE OF THE MANY EXAMPLES WE HAVE
OUT THERE.
WE PASSED AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
FOUR WHICH ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MORE SERIOUS ISSUES RAISED BY
THE FBI INVESTIGATION AND THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT -- AND IT WE
ARE BACK HERE SEEKING TO CLARIFY
THE DEFINITION A REPRESENTATIVE.
I TO ME TOO IN RESPONSE TO
LITIGATION OVER THE MEAING.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN NY
SUPPORTERS.
NO NO WITNESSES APART WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
NONE -- COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE -- IS THE WE NEED
[inaudible]
THE MOTION.
SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OH GREAT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FOR TO CLARIFY YOUR
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION I KNOW
THERE'S PENDING LITIGATION ON
THIS ISSUE WE DO ASK THAT YOU
JUST KEEP US IN THE LOOP.
ON THE LOT LAWSUIT SO WE CAN
EVALUATE WHERE THE LEGISLATION
IS ULTIMATELY NEEDED TO PROVIDE
GREATER CLARITY.
THANK YOU WILL DO.
YOU VERY MUCH US SECRETARY TO
THROW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
ROOM I BOERNER HORVATH BOERNER
HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS RAMESSIDE THREE OF US
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS
VOEPEL [inaudible]
VOEPEL HI.
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
FOR OKAY GREAT.
AB FIVE THIRTY ALLOWS THE
FAIRFIELD SYSOON SEWER DISTRICT
TO EXTEND THEIR SERVICES TO
MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY.
IF APPROVED BY LAUGH GO AND
MAKES MINOR CHANGES TO THEIR
ENABLING ACT.
MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY IS
UNINCORPORATED COUNTY LAND JUST
OUTSIDE THE CITIES OF FAIRFIELD
AND SO SOON.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN SOLANO
COUNTY APPROVED THE DEVELOPMENT
OF FOUR HUNDRED NEW HOMES THERE.
THESE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
REQUIRE A PUBLIC SEWER SYSTEM
THE FAIRFIELD SO SOON SIR
DISTRICT IS THE BEST QUALIFIED
SYSTEM TO SERVICE MIDDLE GREEN
VALLEY.
IN ORDER FOR THE DISTRICT TO
SERVICE THESE NEW HOMES THEY
MUST MAKE CHANGES TO THEIR
ENABLING ACT.
REAL LEGISLATION AB FIVE THIRTY
DOES JUST THAT.
THE DISTRICT IS WORKING ON
LANGUAGE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO REACHING A COMPROMISE
THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE ON I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE -- TODAY WITH
ME I HAVE FAIRFIELD SEE SOON
SEWER DISTRICT AND SUPERVISOR
[inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS GREG BAKER FIND THE
GENERAL MANAGER FOR THE
FAIRFIELD SYSOON SEWER DISTRICT
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS WHO HAVE PASSED A
RESOLUTION IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE THIRTY US
PROVISIONS TO THE ACT -- TO
CLICK TO PROVIDE A CLEAR AND
SPECIFIC PROCESS THAT CURRENTLY
DOES NOT EXIST FOR PROJECTS THAT.
IN THE SOLANO COUNTY MIDDLE
GREEN VALLEY SPECIFIC PLAN AREA.
BECAUSE THE AREAS OUTSIDE THE
CURRENT DISTRICT BOUNDARIES.
THE LAND OF GOSHEN SPEAKING
SEWER SERVICE THROUGH AN OUT OF
AREA SERVICE AGREEMENT. EIGHTY
FIVE THIRTY APPROVED THE
EXTENSION -- WITH A CONDITION
THAT THE SERVICE MUST ALSO BE
APPROVED BY SOLANO COUNTY LAUGH
GO.
UNDER CERTAIN LAUGHTER
REGULATIONS POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES.
NOT HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY PROJECT BUT
RATHER TO SAY THAT'S BEEN TO A
COMPREHENSIVE PROCESSA PUBLIC
PUBLIC STAKEHOLDERS. TO REPEL
ALTAMENTE REACH COMPROMISES TO
MAKE A PROJECT IT IS SUPPORTED --
WITH VERY LITTLE RESISTANCE.
DISTRICT CAN AND IS WILLING TO
SERVE THE PROJECT [inaudible]
AND THE HOWEVER DESPITE.
THE SUPPORT FOR THE PROJECT.
WITHOUT THIS LEGISLATION IT'S
LIKELY THE PROJECT COULD BE TIED
UP IN THE COURTS AND ULTIMATELY
COME BACK TO THIS LEGISLATURE
FOR ULTIMATE RESOLUTION.
RIGHT THIRTY ALSO ADDS
PROVISIONS TO BE ACTED CURRENTLY
DO NOT EXIST. FOR OTHER PROJECTS
SEEKING OUT OF SERVICE -- AT A
VERY A SERVICE AGREEMENTS.
THAT MUST FOLLOW LAUGH GO
REGULATIONS UNDER GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION.
FIVE SIX ONE THREE THREE SO THE
STATE LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE
TO APPROVE THESE PROJECTS ON A
PROJECT BY PROJECT BASIS.
IT ALSO ADDS.
PROVISIONS THAT IT MAKES IT
CLEAR THE DISTRICT CAN PROVIDE.
AND PROCESS ORGANIC WASTE AND TO
BE A SOLUTION PROVIDER AS WE
SPACE THE CHALLENGES OF MANNING
MANAGING ORGANICS.
FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IN
[inaudible]
TWENTY SIXTEEN AT LAST.
THAT PROVIDE THE CLEAN UP OF
SOME OUTDATED LANGUAGE IN THE
CURRENT ACT DATING BACK -- TO
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE LEGACY --
PROCEDURES THAT NO LONGER
APPLICABLE AND WOULD NEED AND
UPDATE CURRENT.
PRACTICES.
BEFORE WE OFFER THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE THREE ZERO
THANK YOU. SEVEN SOLANO COUNTY
SUPERVISOR JIM SPERRIN I I JUST
WANT TO STATE THAT THIS.
BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
COUNTY'S VOTER APPROVED GENERAL
PLAN -- IT DOES NOT PROMOTE
URBAN SPRAWL YOU KNOW THE ALL
THE DESIGNATED AREAS IN THE
COUNTIES ARE OUTLINED IN OUR
GENERAL PLAN I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ADDING A
PROVISION -- FOR THE CAT THAT
CAL LEFT GO THAT IT WOULD GO TO
LAUGH GO FOR APPROVED SENATE
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HANDS
AND LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
MAKING THESE DECISIONS AND
CERTAINLY WOULD HURT YOUR
SUPPORT CARD CARDS THANK YOU.
YET THAT WE CAN SOLVE THIS HERE
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
FAIRFIELD WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY.
WHAT THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
?
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
SURE AGUIAR-CURRY AND INVOICE
AND VICE CHAIR.
MY NAME'S GOING FROM I AM --
REPRESENTING THE SOLANO COUNTY
ORDERLY GROWTH COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE ARE OPPOSED AB FIVE THIRTY
UNLESS AMENDED WE'VE HAD --
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH THE IT
STAFF WITH -- THE CHAIR AT WITH
SIR DISTRICT AND WITH LOCAL
PLAYERS AND SOLANO COUNTY.
THE SLAUGHTER COUNTY EARLY
GROWTH COMMITTEE IS BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL OVER MANY DECADES IN
TERMS OF KEEPING SOLANO COUNTY'S
FARMERS OPEN SPACES WELL
PROTECTED -- THOSE OF YOU WHO
LIVE OR VISIT THE BAY AREA FROM
SACRAMENTO WHEN YOU DRIVE
THROUGH SOLANO COUNTY.
IN FROM DIXON THE VALLEJO IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT -- PORTIONS OF OUR
COUNTY THE REMAIN GREEN
UNDEVELOPED IN VERY PRODUCTIVE
FARMLAND FOR MANY DECADES.
AND THIS ABOUT A PROCESS THAT
HAS NOT BEEN EASY IT'S INVOLVED --
POLICIES POLITICS -- MANY
ELECTIONS INITIATIVES AND
OCCASIONALLY LAWSUIT WHAT WE SEE
TODAY WITH THE LEGISLATION
THAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU.
IS THE SUBTLE LANGUAGE SHOULD
SETTLING WHICH THAT WOULD OPEN
UP A RURAL SOLANO COUNTY TO THE
POSSIBILITY.
OF UNWISE -- SPRAWL TYPE
DEVELOPMENTS IN ON CURRENTLY
WITH ME WELL PROTECTED FARMLANDS
IN SOME CASES WHAT WE'VE SEEN
WITH PROJECTS IN THE COUNTY.
IS THEY'VE BEEN STOPPED OR
STALLED BECAUSE THE INABILITY TO
DO ADEQUATE SEWAGE TREATMENT WE
ALSO TIMES OF PROBLEMS WITH --
PROJECTS HAVE HAD TROUBLE
GETTING -- WATER THEY WANT
MUNICIPAL WATER SUPPLIES WE HAVE
A STRONG POLICY IN SOLANO COUNTY.
OF OF WHAT IS URBAN SHALL BE
MUNICIPAL
AND WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT POLICY CONTINUES.
THE THE LANGUAGE THAT WE
RECOMMENDED IT WHICH WE HOPE YOU
WILL RECEIVE VIA LETTERS THAT
HAVE BEEN SENT IN BY THE EARLY
GROWTH COMMITTEE.
IS THAT TO AMEND THE LANGUAGE OF
THAT LANDS IN THE UNINCORPORATED
PART OF SOLANO COUNTY WOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED TO DELIVER BIO SALAS
TO THE FAIR TEXAS IN PLANTS.
WHAT TO DO WITH THE FAIRFIELD TO
SOON PLAN IN TERMS OF PROCESSING
IS EXCELLENT THE DOING OF
THEY'RE DOING A WONDERFUL JOB OF
TAKING BY ALL SOLID MATERIALS?
RUNNING IT THROUGH AN ADDITIONAL
PROCESSING STEP -- AND THEN
HAVING HIGH QUALITY FERTILIZER
THE GET SENT OUT TO THE TO THE
FARMS IN OUR REGION WE WE THINK
THAT'S JUST TERRIFIC.
THE QUESTION BECOMES WHERE THAT
MATERIAL COMES FROM.
SO WE URGE YOU TODAY TO VOTE NO
ON FIVE THIRTY UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED CAN CAN CONSISTENT WITH.
THE MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE SENT TO
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I I
SHOULD PROBABLY ANNOUNCED THAT
WHICH WE'LL GET TO MAINE AND
WITNESSES.
EITHER SIDE AND THE REST WERE
JUST.
IF OKAY EXPRESSIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOR
DECIDE I REPRESENT THE SECTION
OF FAIRFIELD THAT WILL BE MOST
IMPACTED BY THESE CHANGES.
THE ADDITION OR THE INCLUSION OF
COUNTY PROPERTY.
SO PROPERTIES OUTSIDE OF THE
CITIES [inaudible]
WILL.
INCLUDE INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.%
AND WE ARE READY SEVERELY
IMPACTED.
IN OUR AREA WE'VE GOT
APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
HOMES.
OUR CITY HAS BEEN PROLIFIC IN
WORKING ON DEVELOPMENTS WHICH IS
WONDERFUL THE PROBLEM IS THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT IT.
WE'VE GOT FOUR SCHOOLS.
IN OUR AREA.
WHERE THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY
FOUR THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
CHILDREN THE MAIN ROAD?
THAT PROVIDES ACCESS TO THE
SCHOOLS.
IS JUST TWO LINES YOU HAVE TO
COME TO A FULL STOP BEFORE YOU
CAN ACCESS.
THE FREEWAY.
THE ROADS IN ADEQUATE TRAFFIC
FLOW IS INADEQUATE.
BUT THEN ON TOP OF THAT WE'VE
GOT A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THAT HAS ONLY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. TO INCREASE
CAPACITY [inaudible]
AND WE ARE ALREADY HAVING
PROBLEMS AT OUR SCHOOLS WHERE
THEY ARE.
BEING TURNED AWAY TO OTHER.
SCHOOLS IN THE DISTRICT.
THE SCHOOL CANNOT INCREASE ITS
CAPACITY WE'VE GOT IN OTHER
PARTS OF FAIRFIELD NEAR THE NEW
TRAIN STATION WHERE THERE BE
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND NEW
HOMES.
AND AGAIN THIS IS THE SAME
SCHOOL SYSTEM DOES NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO INCREASE.
SERVICE TO ALL THESE NEW HOMES
THAT ARE BEING APPROVED
[inaudible]
NOT ALLOWING.
THE GREEN THE SKIS ME SPECIFIC
MIDDLE GREEN VALLEY. TO CONNECT
TO THE SEWER SYSTEM IS NOT GOING
TO STOP THE PROJECT.
THEY CAN GO AHEAD AND BUILD IT.
THERE ARE NO SUBJECTS.
SYSTEMS THAT WE USE THEY'LL
BUILD THEIR OWN SEWER SYSTEM AND
WHAT WE NEED.
IS TIME.
THERE IT WILL TAKE TIME FOR THEM
TO DO THAT AND WE NEED THAT TIME
BECAUSE WE ARE ALREADY IN
TROUBLE.
WE JUST CANNOT ACCOMMODATE.
THESE ADDITIONAL FOUR HUNDRED
HOMES WITH WE JUST DON'T HAPPEN
[inaudible]
THE THE THE NUMBER OF HOURS THAT.
PEOPLE SPEND BRING THEIR
CHILDREN TO SCHOOL.
I HAVE A PARENT WHO DESCRIBED IT
AS I COULD HAVE BEEN TO SAN
FRANCISCO AND BACK BUT NO I'M
STUCK IN ALL THIS TRAFFIC.
BECAUSE WE HAVE LIKE I SAY IN
ADEQUATE COULD ROADS.
AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE.
THE WE JUST DON'T HAVE THE
CAPACITY AT THE SCHOOLS HOW IS
IT THAT.
THESE FOUR HUNDRED HOMES WHICH
BY THE WAY THEY'RE NOT
AFFORDABLE HOMES THE HOMES THAT
THAT ARE APPROVED IN CITY.
THERE ARE MUCH MORE AFFORDABLE
IF YOU'RE GONNA COMPARED THEM --
THIS WILL HELP VERY AFFLUENT
PEOPLE. TO THE DETRIMENT OF
THOSE OF US WHO ARE REGULAR
RESIDENTS.
WE DON'T WANNA HAVE.
A CRISIS AND THIS IS.
JUST SETTING UP THE CRISIS IT'S
ALREADY A PROBLEM.
THIS IS A TERRIBLE CRISIS I HOPE.
OF THAT YOU WILL VOTE FOR THE
MEASURES THAT.
X. EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR MIDDLE
BRING VALLEY BEING ALLOWED TO
CONNECT.
BECAUSE THAT ALSO IS JUST.
THE START THERE ARE OTHER.
DEVELOPERS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
DOING THE SAME THING AND AGAIN
SAME PROBLEMS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE ROADS WE DON'T
HAVE DISCO CAPACITY.
PLEASE THINK ABOUT US.
LESS WEALTHY PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO
LIVE IN OUR AREA AND A FOUR
EIGHT A DISASTER WITH OUR
SCHOOLS THANK YOU.
ANY OF THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
HI I'M AMY HEART AND THEN THE
SOLANO COUNTY REGIONAL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR GREEN DOT
ALLIANCE -- WE'RE A NONPROFIT
BASED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA AND WE WORK AT THE
INTERSECTION OF OPEN SPACE
PROTECTION AND SMART GROWTH --
WE ARE ALSO -- TAKING THE
POSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
THIS LEGISLATION COULD
UNINTENTIONALLY OPEN UP PRIME
AGRICULTURAL LAND TO DENSER
DEVELOPMENT -- TO THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS ESTHER PRIOR AND I REPRESENT
RAFEAL HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION.
WHOSE MEMBERS RESIDE IN SIOUX
SOON VALLEY WHICH IS AN
UNINCORPORATED AREA OF SOLANO
COUNTY.
I HOPE THE COMMITTEE HAS
RECEIVED THE COMMUNICATIONS FROM
THE LOCAL RESIDENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
I OPPOSE AB FIVE THIRTY UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S LORDS HER SICK.
I'M A UNINCORPORATED RESIDENCE
SOLANO COUNTY.
AND I OPPOSE EIGHTY FIVE THIRTY
UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
COMMITTED YOU.
MY NAME'S LERI WELL CHAD ELEVEN
ROB FAIL.
IN AYE OPPOSES SAID AND THE
CITIES OF AMENDED BY THE ORDERLY
GROW WHAT WHAT THE ORDERLY
GROWTH.
RECOMMENDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY WE NEED A MOTION TO PASS AS
AMENDED -- TO ADD URGENCY CLAUSE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU -- I YOU KNOW I HEARD
THIS THE OPPOSITION I HEARD A
LOT ABOUT.
SCHOOLS AND ROADS -- BUT THIS IS
ABOUT.
SEWER SERVICE -- I HEARD ONE
SPEAKER -- EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT -- THIS BILL OPENING UP
THE PRIME AG LAND TO DEVELOPMENT.
I'M.
NOT QUITE SURE HOW THAT HAPPENS
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL CAN YOU
EXPLAIN THAT.
SO I ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE ASKING -- FOR THAT NOT I'M
NOT ASKING ABOUT THEM AND I'M
ASKING HOW THE BILL AS IT'S
PROPOSED SHORE CAT -- WOULD
WOULD DO THAT SAID THE
LEGISLATION ALLOWS FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PACKAGE SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANTS AND WHAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT THOSE
PACKAGE SEWAGE TREATMENT PLANTS
COULD BE BUILT.
OUTSIDE OF EXISTING URBAN GROWTH
BOUNDARIES AND SOLANO COUNTY --
FURTHER LEADING TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WOULD BE
CREATING SPRAWL IN THE COUNTY SO
THAT'S IN IT IT WOULD BE ON
PRIME AG LAND SURROUNDING SOLANO
THANK YOU -- I'D LIKE BECAUSE OF
THE AUTHORS EXPERTS TO WITNESSES
TO RESPOND TO THAT IF FOR A IF
YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION. TO
CLARIFY THE GENERAL PLAN OF THE
COUNTY IS APPROVED BY THE VOTERS
OF SOLANO COUNTY ALMOST 75% IN
THIS DISTRICT APPROVED.
NO ZONING NO AGRICULTURAL ZONING
CAN BE CHANGED WITHOUT A VOTE OF
THE PEOPLE.
AND SO WHAT MONDAY TALK ABOUT
URBAN SPRAWL THE CANNOT TAKE
PLACE UNLESS THE GENERAL PLAN IS
AMENDED OR VOTED ON BY THE
PUBLIC AND SO.
IT DOES NOT CREATE URBAN SPRAWL
THERE'S A DESIGNATED AREAS AND
COUNTY THAT CAN BE DEVELOPED
THAT'S ALL THAT CAN BE.
DEVELOPED IN THE COUNTY.
THEN THE THE OTHER -- CONCERN I
HEARD WAS THAT.
SOMEHOW -- THE SEWERS -- SEWER
SERVICE WAS GOING -- TO AND THAT
BEING BROUGHT FROM ONE AREA INTO
ANOTHER AREA AND MAYBE YOU CAN
EXPLAIN THAT A LITTLE BETTER
THAN I JUST TRIED.
TO ARTICULATE A CAN YOU RESTATE
THAT AND SURE.
A FURTHER EXPLAIN SURE DOING
CRIME AGAIN SO THE THE FAIRFIELD
TO SOON SEWER DISTRICT PLANT
WHICH BY DEFINITION FEARFUL TO
SENATE WAS BUILT TO ACCOMMODATE
TO CITIES.
BUT OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS OR
THREE YEARS GREG.
THEY'VE IMPORTER THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY -- CAME OUT OF CANADA
THIS IS THE TO TRAFFIC
TECHNOLOGY THAT RUNS -- BILE
SALTS BOTH FROM THEIR PLANT AND
FROM OTHER PLANTS AROUND THE BAY
AREA THEIR TRUCKED INTO THE
FAIRFIELD TO SOON PLANT. TO
TREAT THOSE BIOSOLIDS TO IT TO A
HIGHER DEGREE OF CLEANLINESS
PURITY.
THE BECOME A HIGHER QUALITY
FERTILIZER I THINK IS PROBABLY
YOU KNOW EMINEM MUCH WITH MUCH
OF WHILE SOLDIERS WHO TREATMENT
PLANTS.
IS APPLIED LAND APPLIED ACROSS.
THE STATE PROBABLY ACROSS
COUNTRY HEARING AREAS TO USE AS
FERTILIZER.
SO THE ABILITY TO BRING IN THAT
MATERIAL RIGHT NOW IT'S PROBABLY
NOT ALLOWED UNDER THE EXISTING
SEWER DISTRICT LEGISLATION.
WERE NOT WHEN IT COMES FROM
OTHER -- OUTSIDE AREAS OUTSIDE
OF FAIRFIELD TO SOON.
WE THINK IT'S A FINE IDEA TO
BRING AND STUFF FROM.
MUNICIPAL SEWAGE TREATMENT
PLANTS THAT SERVE YOU
INCORPORATED AN URBANIZED AREAS.
IN IN THE RURAL AREAS WE'VE HAD
A COUPLE OF THE PROPOSED AND
SOLANO COUNTY -- SUPERVISORS
BERRY AND I GO BACK AND FORTH
REGULARLY ON DEVELOPMENT ISSUES.
BUT THERE'S BEEN REGULAR
PROPOSALS TO HAVE -- FANCIER
SEPARATE TYPE SYSTEMS AFTER
PUMPED OUT PACKAGE SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANTS THAT THEN THEY
HAVE TO GET RID OF THEIR
MATERIAL THAT THEY CAN'T BRING
IT UP TO A HIGH ENOUGH QUALITY.
ON SITE TO HANDLE WITH THE
REGIONAL WATER QUALITY CONTROL
BOARD REQUIRES SO IF THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO SOMETHING OF A
LOWER QUALITY TREATMENT SYSTEM
ON SITE.
AND THEN HOLD THE MATERIALS TO
THE FAIRFIELD TO SOME PLANT.
GOOD ENVIRONMENTALLY AFTER
PROJECTS BEEN BUILT.
BUT IF THAT ENCOURAGES AND
INCENTIVIZE IS PROJECTS TO BE
BUILT IN THAT PLACES WE HAVE A
CONCERN THAT'S ALL OUR CONCERN
IS.
DON'T INCENTIVIZE THE
POTENTIALITY.
OF PUTTING SUBDIVISION
DEVELOPMENTS ON FARM LET.
AND WHAT IF I COULD GET A RISK I
MIGHT OUT TONIGHT I'M
CERTIFICATION THE BILL DOESN'T
ADD THE PROVISIONS TO PUT IN THE
SORT OF PACKAGE TREATMENT PLANTS
THAT ALREADY EXISTS THOSE CAN BE
DONE.
REGARDLESS OF THIS BILL IF THE
COUNTY APPROVED THE PROJECTS
THEY CAN BUILD THESE ON SITE
TREATMENT SYSTEMS AND THEY CAN.
TRUCK THAT TO ANY OTHER FACILITY
THIS BILL WOULD ONLY PREVENT
THEM FROM TRACKING IT TO THE IT
AS AMENDED BY.
THE ORDERLY GROWTH PEOPLE.
WOULD ONLY PROHIBIT THAT FROM
COMING TO THE FAIRFIELD TOO SOON
SEWER DISTRICT NOT TO THE PLANTS
IN BACK OF BILL OR DELAYED OR
BENICIA OR ANY OTHER PLANT
THROUGHOUT SOLANO COUNTY SO THAT.
THIS DOES NOT HELP THAT
PARTICULAR PROVISION.
OKAY -- I THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE I I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
OPPOSITION TO THIS I'VE SEEN
THIS KIND OF OPPOSITION -- COME
UP ALL ACROSS THE THAT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA -- WHEN -- FOLKS
DON'T WANT TO SEE DEVELOPMENT TO
HAPPEN I UNDERSTAND IT I GET IT --
BUT WE'RE IN THE MIDST OF A
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND TO WE SHOULD BE ENCOURAGING
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPMENT.
I DON'T SEE THAT THIS IS A
RESPONSIBLE SIMPLY BECAUSE
SOMETHING MIGHT HAPPEN -- THE
OPPOSITION SEEMS VERY
SPECULATIVE TO MAY AND TO AND
PLEASE TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL.
SUMMARY YES AND I JUST YOU KNOW
I A I CAN QUOTE THE COMMENTS YOU
KNOW I UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION
AND THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE RISK OF OF THIS YOU
KNOW.
POTENTIAL -- THE DEVICE FOR THE
BUILDINGS GOOD PLANNING I THINK
IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A SOMETHING
THAT'S WELL GROUNDED -- IN THE
ANALYSIS BUT YOU KNOW THE THINGS
I HEARD ABOUT ROAD ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
YOU KNOW -- HAD A YOU KNOW.
NOT BEEN IN THIS ROOM IN HER
THOSE COMMENTS I'D BE LIKE NOW
THEY TALKING ABOUT THE SALINAS
VALLEY AS MY DISTRICT.
A BECAUSE WE SUFFER -- AS WELL --
AND IT'S THESE KIND OF
CONDITIONS THAT HAVE -- THEY'VE
DEPRESSED THE HOUSING IN OUR
AREA AND REALLY.
THROUGHOUT ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND
WHAT'S THE END RESULT FOR US I
MEAN WORK COUNTY MONTEREY COUNTY
IT LEADS THE STATE IN STUDENT
HOMELESSNESS.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING
IN OVERCROWDED -- YOU KNOW
HOUSES THERE -- IN.
THE THESE TERRIBLE CONDITIONS --
AND SO REALLY -- YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO DO MORE TO SUPPORT OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES AND
IN PROPER PLANNING IS PART OF
THAT PROCESS SO I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
AS CHAIR SYSTEM REAL QUICK ON
THE ASPECT OF THE LAUGHED
BECAUSE IN THE AREAS THAT
INCREASING THE SPEED OF
INFLUENCE OR IS IT STILL A
PROCESS.
THE NEED TO GO THROUGH LEFT --
AND THEN UPON THE COMPLETION OF
THAT AND APPROVAL OF THAT THESE
PLANS GOING TO INTO EFFECT.
CAN BE OBVIOUSLY WE I ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE LEFT GO WHEN YOU CAN
BECAUSE IT GIVES US ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE PUBLIC
OUTREACH IN THIS THAT PROCESS
WILL HAPPEN.
IN THESE INDIVIDUALS AS WELL CAN --
BE AT THOSE THAT THE TABLE THOSE
AS WELL LEFT BECAUSE IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THIS THEY IT THE
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THIS WITH
THE GENERAL PLAN WITH US SOLANO
COUNTY.
FOR QUITE SOME TIME IS ACCEPTED
BY THE RESIDENTS THEY VOTED ON
IT -- THEY'VE HAD LOTS OF PUBLIC
OUT REACH BUT THIS THEY'VE EVEN
AGREED TO DO THE SECOND STEP.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THERE'S NO OTHER QUESTIONS
AS SECRETARY ONE CALL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE AN EMERGENCY CLAUSE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY AYE LACKEY
AYE BLOOM LIKE BLOOM I'VE BURNER
**** ABOUT.
BURNER HEART THAT I RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MISSION ST.
MEASURES OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH THINGS GET WE'RE GOING TO
ADD ONS [inaudible]
OKAY -- I MISSED.
I'LL BE HERE.
I THINK SO.
A WHICH I CAN'T SEE MOST OF THE
SO.
ITEM WHEN AB SIXTY EIGHT TING
THE MOTION IS TO PASS RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
LACKEY.
NO LACKEY NO.
RAMOS RAMOS HI.
ITEM TO AB TWO SEVENTY FOUR
MATHIS MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RAMOS.
RAMOS SIGH.
ITEM THREE AB THREE OH FIVE
NECESSARY AND DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS RAMOS.
ON A SIDE [inaudible]
ITEM.
FOUR A. B. FORTY FIVE MEDINA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY HI.
ITEM SIX AB FIVE EIGHTY SEVEN
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIGH.
ITEM SEVEN A. B. FIVE NINETY
WHEN CRISTINA GARCIA THE MOTION
IS TO PASS ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I ITEM EIGHT
INCLUDES THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEMS EIGHT AND ITEM TWELVE AB
SIX THIRTY TWO AND A. B.. TEN
EIGHTY FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY HI.
ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I ITEM NINE AB SIX
EIGHTY NINE MCCARTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I ITEM.
FOR TEN AB EIGHT EIGHT ONE BLOOM.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BURNER
**** ABOUT [inaudible]
RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS I ITEM ELEVEN AB EIGHT
NINE FORTY FIVE MCCARTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. TO THE
BANKING AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I ROBERT RIVAS
[inaudible]
ROBERT RIVAS I ITEM FIFTEEN AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN REYES THE
MOTION IS. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ITEM SIXTEEN A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY SIX TANGO
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO RAMOS RAMOS I ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB FIVE FIFTEEN FIFTY
ONE DOLLY -- THE MOTIONS TO PASS
TO THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS SIGH.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY CARILLO CARRILLO.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE.
ITEM NINETEEN AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO FLORA THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE.
ITEM TWENTY AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
THREE BLOOM THE MOTION IS TO
PASS RAMOS [inaudible]
RAMOS SIGN [inaudible]
CAN.
WELL DONE TO IT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT DO CAN MAKE YOU?
YEAH [inaudible]
MEETING ADJOURNED